There we go.
Now it's,
now we're on ladies and gentlemen,
we're sort of on time.
We try to get it right every week,
but every week we fucked something up.
And this week I made sure that I turned off the sound on my computer.
The one over there,
I haven't even turned off the sound on this one yet.
So
you got my mind.
He didn't do yours.
It could have easily been me that just fucked up,
which is,
that's the reason why I fucked up.
It's cause cause I'm here cause I always fuck it up.
I fuck it up.
Every week we'd done this Goddamn thing like 22 weeks in a row.
I fuck it up every single time.
This week it was Brian,
you know,
uh,
I've been thinking about this podcast a lot,
ladies and gentlemen,
and a,
one of the things I've been thinking about is I appreciate the fuck out of
everybody listening.
And uh,
we,
we do try our best to make this as interesting as possible and as smooth and
professional as possible.
But I got to admit that I've been too stressed out about this.
I've been taking it too seriously.
I mean,
uh,
taking it seriously in a good way.
Whereas we improve the sound.
We've got a real mixer and we got to,
I mean,
we're sitting on couches and shit and we're going to get better cameras,
but that like,
it's not like there's a part of it that's really fun,
but there's a part of it that wasn't fun and I don't think that should exist.
I don't think I should ever get too serious about this.
This is for people who are working,
who are being distracted that just wants something because they're doing
mindless shit.
This is for people that are driving in their cars and you know,
want something to listen to.
This is for people on the train.
This is for people at the gym.
Whatever the fuck it's for you guys.
All right.
And if,
if we take it too seriously,
you stop being yourself and it starts,
starts being like this professional thing that you're trying real hard to do.
And uh,
I think,
uh,
I think I've fallen prey to that a little bit.
I was thinking about it today.
Have to,
it took a little bit of a hit a weed and I was thinking about it and I was like,
you know what man,
this thing,
like I'm,
I'm like,
I paid too much attention to it and she'd just be a weekly fun thing like it or
not,
you know,
for,
for anybody who's like minded or anybody who's interested in some sort of a
distraction from someone who's not likeminded.
Well knowing you jail,
you do that a lot on a lot of things.
Every kid fucking freak.
I got problems pull.
Yeah.
Listen,
this is my number one,
my number one problem in life.
It's like I try very hard to,
to uh,
advance as a human being.
I try to evolve.
I tried to fix whatever issues that I have with myself,
whatever errors that I've made in my life.
I tried to never make them more than once.
You know,
I try to constantly be moving,
but if I have a,
an ongoing theme with problems in my life,
the number one thing is with obsessions.
I get obsessed with shit to the point where,
um,
like especially games,
but it doesn't have to be games.
It could be we talked about this could be beating off,
it could be,
it could be fucking anything.
I just get,
uh,
my,
my head gets super focused on things and it's good in some ways because it
allows you to like put a lot of energy into things and work really hard at
things and that can allow you to become successful.
I mean,
that's the reason why I got successful with martial arts,
with comedy,
with anything because,
because I became
obsessed with it.
But um,
it's good if you're like a mindless person,
it's good to force you to doing something.
You're not even sure why you're doing it.
You're just doing it and you're getting good at it.
You know,
you're getting this reward,
but you're not really contemplating whether or not you're putting too much
energy and effort into one certain thing.
You know,
you know what I'm talking about.
It becomes like,
it doesn't become like a conscious thing.
It becomes like a,
like this is a positive thing.
I'm,
I'm doing this,
I'm moving in this direction.
It becomes an obsession and it becomes,
you just just have this need.
Like with video games,
I had it,
I had a really bad with quake,
really bad with,
I would play eight 10 hours a day and I would be talking to someone and if they
said a fucking single thing that was boring,
I'd be like,
why am I even talking to you when I could be playing quake?
That's what I'd be thinking like you,
you know,
I'd be like hanging out with my check.
I'd be,
we'd be having a conversation about something and I would be like nodding my
head and I'm thinking,
how much more time do I have to talk to her before I could sneak away and go
play quick
when the first times I met you online,
we used to play quake and there was one time in particular we've,
I don't know if we've talked about this,
where we played,
I think you killed me 120 times in a row.
I hadn't killed you once and you kept on going and I was like,
ah,
I want to stop.
And you're like,
no,
we're not.
Come on.
It was,
by the way,
I'm obsessing about the fleshlight.
We should say this.
That means we have to,
we have to thank our sponsor.
We have a sponsor.
I was,
we're sponsored by the fleshlight fleshlight.com and if you go to Joe Rogan's
website and click on his banner on the right side,
you get 15
person on.
This is how we say it.
If you beat off,
and I know you do.
Okay.
This is a product that makes beating off way better.
It's really that simple.
You know,
there's a lot of emotional and psychological shit attached to buying a fake
pussy that you're actually gonna stick your Dick in.
It's like a,
not a very manly thing.
What did you think about money that you spend on and you tell everybody about
like a new loofa sponge?
Dude,
I got this fucking sponge.
It's on the stickers to shit.
Fucking get in the good old,
you know?
I mean people like get all,
like you could talk about pleasurable things as long as it doesn't involve you
doing
dick,
that shit changes your life too.
Like I tried to masturbate with my hand cause I was too lazy to bend over and
get the reach and get the fleshlight that was on the key thing behind me and I
tried to masturbate with my hand and like halfway through I was like,
this is stupid.
I need to go get my flashlight really is good.
Yeah.
It's because first of all,
you can
enjoy it fully because no matter how much it feels good to be rubbing on your
deck,
that's only half of your brain.
The other half of your brain is going,
oh my God,
I have a Dick in my hand.
There's a certain amount of your brain that like knows like you're jerking off a
deck.
Even if it's your own Dick.
Even if feels good,
there's still a,
there's,
there's some torment there.
You know,
there's uh,
some,
some conflict.
I got it.
I got to show you something,
judge.
Something happened to me the other day when I was using it.
And I need to warn anybody that has a fleshlight not to do this.
This is not your used one.
Right.
All right.
So like when you pull,
when you pull it out the quake,
you just like pull a fish out of a bucket.
It's crazy.
So anyways,
when you,
when you go to clean it,
I,
the end of it,
when you don't have this little metal thing or the plastic thing in here,
I'll hold up to the camera.
There's like a hole that you attached to your um,
faucet.
Now I've been like attaching it to my faucet,
you know,
the water goes through it and blows out the fuck hole by,
I've been like holding it like a,
uh,
a hose at the end of it.
So it fills up with water and shoots to come out real fast.
Kind of like,
you know,
well,
the problem is I was so stoned when I did it that held it and I was facing
myself in,
it's all over my face.
No,
swear to God.
I don't know.
I don't know if the come had already popped out because I,
you know,
I didn't do it right when it did.
You shut your own load,
your mugs.
So watch out fleshlight owners if you clean it that way you don't aim for the
face.
How do you stuffed it back in and he just forced it back in.
There's been there,
I don't even know if I'm doing it right cause I don't read the directions to
anything.
But I think you just probably the directions to shit.
Isn't that weird?
Was the last time you read directions to anything?
Honestly,
I don't remember the last time I read it
and for my kids it has to be something where it's not involving me and there's
like danger and I have to make sure everything's set up okay.
I put together a crib recently and I had,
I looked at all the directions.
It was kind of complicated.
It was really tricky.
It took like an hour,
you know,
maybe cause I'm a moron,
but it did take an hour,
you know,
back when I was doing construction back in the day I could adopt.
Got done about 50 minutes.
55.
Right.
Um,
but uh,
yeah,
I don't look at the directions.
That shit.
Yeah,
it's easy.
It's like a challenge.
It's like a Rubik's cube to me.
Like I need to figure everything out myself.
Well also one of the things that I love,
I'm in a,
I hate to be a a guy was a windows or a Mac guy.
You know,
cause I think it's a stupid argument.
But if you don't have fucking computer at all,
I've never had a computer and you're a reasonably intelligent person.
You can navigate your way around a Mac,
you know?
You know what I'm saying?
Like someone goes like this,
see this,
this is where the mouse is,
this,
this track thing.
And if you go down here,
see that's called a finder.
When you click on that,
see everything opens and there's all right there.
Whatever you want.
What do you need?
Do you need a movie?
Do you need to your email,
you know,
do what?
What do,
what do you need?
It's all right there.
I don't like things that are too complicated that are overly pain in the ass.
Complicated like this fucking MP,
three player that things a little complicated,
complicated this.
There's shit that we buy like this ms mixer.
What the fuck is all going on in there?
I'm so glad that I have a brain though that that wants to figure things out.
So to me like I have,
it's like a challenge.
So luckily I hope that never stops though because I don't want to be like,
you know one of those people that just after a certain age they give up on a
computers or they give up on the cell phones and VCRs,
people
that I've ever met.
You are the number one best at figuring out like computer type shit and figuring
out like software shit and like you got a weird mind for it dude.
Like someone can give you a cell phone,
like a new cell phone.
You're like,
oh gee.
Even know that you could do this.
You can get ringtone sent to your house and then could,
you can call somebody with this and it's fine.
You can eat it immediately.
As soon as you get up in the morning,
it'll go to an internet connection and it'll show you what your emails for the
day.
Like you just press this part right here.
If people like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
And even know it did that.
Like you find like weird shit on phones,
that weird things that they can do.
Like,
you know,
there's,
there's a certain part of your brain,
man that uh,
it just goes right to like weird fucking like secret shit.
Yeah.
The problem with that though,
everything's so fucking complicated that when something goes wrong at my
household,
it's like fucking nuclear war.
I mean,
it's,
it's like,
okay,
the movie stopped streaming.
I gotta go to the computer in the living room that's broadcasting into my
slingbox that's now,
but going over my wifi connection.
All right.
So you know,
it's like that.
It's not just like,
oh no,
just hit the power button on and off and blow into it.
Yeah.
When I was at your place here the day just being in your office,
it's like,
dude,
what are you doing?
You controlling some fucking,
you know,
some,
some hidden cameras somewhere am operating an empire.
It's like there's so much electronic shit in your,
your office,
if you were like,
like,
it's like a scene in the matrix,
you know,
you go into the dude's dusty basement and he's got these fucking computers,
Rick debates have,
you've got like all sorts of them,
all kinds of nutty shit.
You,
you're the only one that I know that's even thought about getting a fucking
three D TV.
You have a three d TV man
bedroom.
That's a weird thing.
You know what's crazy though,
is that uh,
this person I know,
unfortunately their house burned down a,
their alarm clock caught on fire and shorty,
I've heard of that happening more than once.
Right.
And W W scares the fuck out of me that an alarm clock did that.
But then you go into my office and there was more wires and fucking shit
everywhere and dust balls in freeing me up.
You know,
it's crazy.
Yeah,
it is.
Electricity.
It just as itself is fucking crazy.
I mean we don't think about it because we have it,
but if electricity didn't exist and someone all of a sudden came along with an
infinite source of energy,
not infinite,
but like infinitely powerful,
like you can fucking power fucking cities.
Okay.
And you,
it's running through your house all the time and you just stick something and
it's got a little tiny piece of plastics that's protecting you from sure death
and there's just two metal prongs and you're going to insert them into the
fucking source.
And this source is plugged into a grid that powers the whole Goddamn fucking
city.
It's that powerful and it's all running through there and you just,
you just plug into it and you're constantly attached to it.
You'll leave the lights on all night,
you fucking don't even think about it.
You go to sleep with the TV on and there's just this fucking mad about of energy
surging through your house.
Do you remember a lector sets?
Is that what they're called?
Where they were like,
yeah.
I don't know.
When you're a kid you could like build like robots,
you know,
they had like batteries and stuff like that and it was,
it was like Lincoln logs but with like kind of remember this,
I think that's what it was called,
but there was a,
uh,
I had a wire when I think it was like four years old,
had a wire and I had this bright idea to take the wire I want what my idea was,
I wanted to take electricity from the top outlet and move it to the bottom
outlet.
So I put a wire in the top outlet and a water in the bottom outlet and it blew
up like sparks and I flew across the room and I'm like,
that is amazing that that shit happened can happen so easily.
Like to,
that shit is so scary.
Yeah.
You have kids.
Do you have all that shit on all your outlets?
Yeah.
And a little clips that go with outlets.
Most of
them right there.
No,
she comes into my office when I'm not here.
She can start pulling on shit.
Yeah,
it's scary.
You know when you have little kids too,
it's like they don't know.
Like you can't just tell them something to go,
hey stupid,
why didn't you listen?
Like they don't know that they have to listen.
They don't understand that there's consequences.
You know when you have a two year old you have to like there's,
there's,
you can never be upset at them.
You always have to just be correcting them and then giving them like a affection
and positive energy.
Like when they do something wrong,
you got to say no,
you shouldn't do that.
Should always be nice.
She could be nice if you're nice and everybody's happy,
but if you're not nice and people get sad,
right?
So why should we be nice?
Cause you know what?
Make everybody sad.
Yes.
And you give him a hug.
It's like you can,
you develop a human being.
You can't be upset at them.
But if they're fucking adults,
you know,
you're like,
hey stupid,
don't stick your fucking fork in the thing.
You'll die.
But you're sure,
go ahead dickhead.
You want to stick your fork in there?
Go ahead.
You know?
But with babies,
man,
you,
you have like a little you that you love as much if not more than yourself and
they don't know anything,
so you have to make sure they don't run down a flight of stairs.
They fall all the time.
You have to be real careful,
but they have enough energy to talk to you but they don't understand yet.
But then why are some babies completely like,
did you see that video of a baby smoking two packs of cigarettes at j two year
old baby?
So many people were trying to tell me that that was fake.
It was,
it was so disturbing that I put it up on Twitter and I got hundreds of fucking
people on Facebook.
People did it on the message board.
People did.
A bunch of people were saying that it's fake.
How is it fake?
It's not fake CTI on a carrot,
but like dues were angry.
One guy was like,
you know on Twitter was like,
don't fucking post up that dump fake shit.
Don't support trolls.
I'm like,
dude,
that's a baby smoking cigarettes.
This shit is real.
This really is a fucking two year old.
It's funny because I,
on my website I had used to collect baby videos and photos and videos of babies
smoking cigarettes cause it's just a ridiculous,
and now it's like that's a common,
it's really common.
Overseas babies will have cigarettes overseas.
How crazy is that?
That you can take a little tiny little baby that you love and you're,
you're teaching at the world and you let it smoke a cigarette
and if they're so good at it too,
like I was watching that video and I'm like,
man,
that baby was better than smoking cigarettes than I was.
I mean he was just like flipping it around.
He was acting cool with it.
Two packs a day.
Every day they say the baby doesn't have any energy to play with his friends and
if you don't give the baby cigarettes,
he goes fucking crazy.
He goes crazy and starts screaming.
That's so crazy.
That's the problem with human beings,
man,
is that there's,
there's,
there's a broad spectrum of us and the broad spectrum is necessary in order to
have this sort of a complex society.
Until we invent robots that are going to do shitty jobs,
we're going to need monkeys.
We're going to need dumb fucking people.
We're going to need idiots.
You know,
that's a terrible way to look at the world.
And it doesn't necessarily mean that anybody born into the idiot family has to
be an idiot.
That doesn't necessarily mean that the idiots can't like snap out of it if
somehow they do mushrooms or take a yoga class or try to look at their life in a
different way.
But for many people,
the reason why they're idiots is not necessarily that their brain doesn't work
that well.
So they got in a terrible pattern,
like really early in life and they have become a dumb fuck and they're stuck and
they're,
they live with a bunch of other dumped fox,
so they get all this negative energy all the time.
They're constantly dealing with conflicts at home that are meaningless but
distract them from from getting good at anything in life or from getting your
own personal shit together because all your energy is being diverted towards
conflicts like that's why it's so important to not have negative people in your
life because if you're trying to evolve and I think I know you are and I am and
all of our friends are,
everyone's trying to improve as a person,
it's very difficult to fucking figure out how to be a person.
It's very difficult to figure out how to manage your energy and they know when
you're wrong and know when you're being upset for no reason.
It's a tricky thing,
you know,
and you,
one of the most important things about it is you need to pay attention.
You need to have time to,
to think about your own,
your own interactions with other people,
to think about like the way you behave,
to think about the way you think,
to think about like the direction that you're moving in the,
in the world.
It takes a long time.
It takes a lot of energy and if your energy is being spent constantly dealing
with bullshit,
constantly dealing with fucking stupid fights that are over nothing with your
girlfriend or with a buddy who's a shithead and always apologizes.
But then as a shithead again,
you know,
if you ever have a friend like that that does like shitty things to,
like,
like fuck's this guy's ex girlfriend or something and does it in some sort of a
creepy way and doesn't tell them or you know,
fucking steal some of your shit and doesn't bring it back or you'll lend them
money and he doesn't pay you back.
Yeah,
let's just do shit that sort of piles on like as soon as something like that
happens in a relationship with a friend,
like you automatically start paying too much attention to it.
It automatically becomes like,
okay,
now this isn't an enhancing relationship anymore.
This isn't,
you know,
I hang around with you and we have a great time.
You know,
you,
you say funny shit.
I laugh.
I think about things differently cause I think about it from your point of view.
You think about things from my point of view,
because we're totally different human beings.
It's an enhancing experience.
But when you have shitheads in your life and people that aren't thinking about
evolving and people that aren't they,
they're not,
they haven't subscribed to the right,
the,
the right energy.
They haven't subscribed to the right direction in their life.
So they're,
they're not,
they don't have their shit together.
So you're constantly like dealing with conflict when you're around them.
When you do that and you put yourself in those sorts of situations,
you will fuck yourself.
You those,
that,
that is an energy vampire.
And there's so many people that get locked into relationships and friendships
and work situations.
I mean,
how many people just fucking hate the people they work with because you're with
the people you work with even more than you're with your spouse.
You know,
most people,
you get home at night,
it's six o'clock.
How long are you going to be awake?
You're going to be away for another four hours.
You're going to go to sleep at 10 probably you're going to crash.
You gotta be at work in the morning,
you know,
you've got your fucking tired.
So if you think about it,
how much time you're spending with your spouse,
your spouse,
and your kids,
you know,
between commuting and all that shit.
It's like you're dealing with like three hours a night,
but you're working,
you're dealing with people eight hours a day working for the weekends.
And you know,
that song was a real man,
their song in Israel.
So I was working nine to five.
Yeah,
I watched that movie the other day.
There's two songs about working.
That's great.
Dolly Parton always seem to me to be this kind of sexy chick put that if you
fucked her,
you wouldn't be happy with it.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
You don't,
I'm talking about like,
even back then was,
she was undeniably hot,
you know,
and the nine to five days that are big titties and her blonde hair and that's
Texas accent.
Dude's love Dolly Parton.
It's one of the reasons why she was in all these movies.
She was so attractive.
You know,
her whole persona.
But it just seems to me that she's one of those checks.
You fuck her and then the,
the mystery is gone and then you find out what's really going on behind the
scenes and you get all sad.
A couple of days later you walk in your bedroom,
it's humidity and perfume.
Old perfumed smelled like Avon was in there and somebody had an assistant.
I do not like perfume,
dude.
I hate perfume.
I hate perfume and makeup.
I mean,
I don't mind a teeny bit of makeup on a girl,
but when girls are all dolled out to me,
that just creeps me out.
There's something weird about it for sure,
especially if they need to do it.
When you leave the house,
you know,
it's like,
like you need to,
you can't,
you can't go out until you put your face on.
That's like a,
that's a creepy thing man.
The worst is when their lips are sticky because of lip gloss or lipstick and you
kiss them and sticks to the weird thing that we just accept the fact that people
put stuff on their face to change the color of their face.
I mean it's not a bizarre fucking thing.
I mean we know that human beings are attracted to certain things and so they
figured out how to make someone more attractive.
You know,
like when they figured out how to put makeup around the eyes to make you center
on the eyes,
you know like smokey and low.
She's mysterious cries or smoky.
Like what does that supposed to represent?
I never understood the smoky color.
Like if you're going to get crazy and pretend that the top of your eyes are
blue.
Okay.
I've dealt with,
I was at the Improv last night.
Mexican girl came up and she had like blue huge things and was just like,
what are at,
it's like almost like you're a bit trying to be a superhero or,
yeah,
there's a weird thing,
man.
It's a weird thing.
I know Chris Rock had a really funny joke about that about women are untruthful
just by being there and she's like,
that's easy.
It was really wearing makeup.
That's not what your face looks like.
Why are you wearing those heels?
You ain't that tall.
I mean really it is.
It is so true.
It's a strange thing and the,
the biggest strange one to me is the fake tit.
Yeah,
fake tit is the weirdest thing ever because it works.
I know it works with me.
It makes me excited.
But meanwhile,
what is it?
It's a fucking bag of water.
It's based in a chicks chest,
but it's not even boobs are real boob Ma is much sexier because you're grabbing
a gland,
like you feel like the woman's like there's,
it's a sexual organ.
Like if,
if,
if a girl has like big real tits,
even if she has small real tits and they're sensitive,
like when you grab them,
they get excited.
Like you feel like you're,
it's like you're grabbing their pussy.
It's like you're grabbing a sexual affectionate part of their body.
A part that's very sensitive,
but when you grab a bag of water,
man,
that's just trippy,
right?
Well,
you know,
I,
I've only touched like a fake boob like once or twice,
you know,
luckily I've only dated girls with real boobs.
You've been very lucky.
But the thing is,
even if they're failing,
it's still attractive.
You know,
that's the nuttiest thing about human beings.
Just like we know that the eye makeup is eye makeup.
We know you don't really have avatar eyes right at the top of your eyes aren't
fucking blue.
Right?
But,
but somehow or another,
it's attractive.
You know,
that bright red lipstick that you have on somehow or another that's attractive.
The fact that I know those aren't even really your eyelashes.
I don't care.
It's attractive.
Why they shouldn't be boobs on their face.
And then instead of makeup,
you know,
like lipstick,
just draw boobs and make it look like your cheeks are boom,
will you silly goose what they're trying to look,
they don't want to look like a freak.
Anything.
It's like the,
there's like there's a evolutionary line between something that stands out and
something that has like,
there's certain things that obviously genetically we look for.
We look for eyes,
we look for like the connection,
the energy inside someone's eyes.
And that's why people who have a wonky eye or something like that or a trip to
look at,
it's cause you know,
you're always going to,
there's in the back of your head,
you're always gonna think the part of the conversation is going to be this.
There's a wonky eye,
you know,
try not to freak out,
try not to,
you know,
ask questions wit to which one to look at and try not to switch eyes and look at
the left one,
the right one.
Just focus on one.
Right.
And stick with it.
There's,
there's something evolutionary about that.
And when you add shit like a tit to a face,
like that's not cool anymore.
Now cause now you're,
you have something that's in the wrong place and you want,
everything has to be,
I know I'm being serious,
I'm just saying that everything has to be in the right order.
You know,
you can't have three hot eyes,
you know,
and for girls,
really sexy smokey eyes.
She can't have one of your
fucking for what though?
That seemed from what total recall with the third boob chick that was still hot
to me.
Really?
Yeah.
I think I masturbated about that when I was younger.
Wow.
You didn't think that was hot?
No.
My instincts are like,
oh,
okay.
But when you see a cat that's already had babies,
you know how they're in their nipples are hanging after the babies.
That's still hotter to me then not having those nipples.
Then you know there's fake three tip porn on the Internet to Dick Porn Porn.
Yeah,
there is.
I've seen it before.
There's fake Dick porn too.
There's tentacle porn,
my favorite.
There's one where there's this black dude who is always,
he always keeps his pants on it.
That's how he know he's got a fake Dick.
He's got like some sort of a strap on thing and he pulls his dick out of his
pants and it's ridiculous.
It's literally like as long as your arm.
Oh yeah.
It's ridiculous.
And the girls were like,
oh my God,
they start sucking on it.
But rubber,
Dick's looked so good today.
It's hard to tell that it's rubber deck,
you know?
So he like fucks all these girls with his giant and
yeah,
it's weird because when I used to first see those videos,
I never thought it was fake.
I just thought that black guys had core sticks and I was like,
wow,
that guy has some crazy horse stick.
But then you start noticing like the fucking,
they're always holding it down by the base to make it,
you know?
So you know,
well let me ask you this.
Here's a hypothetical.
Say you were dating a girl and she decided she was going to start doing girl on
girl a porno films.
Okay.
You know,
you'd be like,
all right,
that's cool.
Just checks.
It wouldn't bother me at all.
Right,
right.
But how would you feel about a dude fucking or with a fake dick
if they're dudes in the room?
That's what would bother me.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Snaking not as fake rubber debt.
Even if there's a guy camera,
man,
that doesn't bother me.
But the guy in sexual poses,
the guys like
buddy and like they're married to other people and it's all just for work.
You don't have to worry about it.
It's all you fucking her with his real dick.
He wouldn't do that
Spec for his wife.
He used to just big fat black Dick.
Yeah,
that's still different to me.
I don't know.
Maybe they grew up together and then they're like,
totally like
brothers and sisters,
man.
Then they're not even,
they don't even think about each other sexually.
It's disgusting.
Okay.
But you know they have mouths to feed.
Why are you asking me the guy with the fake rubber Dick as a family?
Okay.
Why don't you think about him,
Brian.
We've got with the fake rubber Dick needs to feed his children.
Okay.
Now why am I bringing this up?
Yeah.
I don't know,
man,
because I'm a fascinated by fake tit porn.
Fake that you know,
there's only,
you know,
there was a Guy Max hardcore.
Do you know who that Guy Max?
So of course I do.
You know that guy's in jail,
right?
Yes.
He's the only God that I can think of in recent memory that has not just been
arrested for pornography,
but tried for,
um,
for obscenity and convicted in 2009,
you know,
and he's in jail.
And um,
when I first heard about it,
it was really disturbing because I was like,
Whoa,
okay,
this guy is just making pornography like what he's doing,
like extra dirty pornography.
What is he doing?
What the fuck would he be doing?
I mean,
there's anybody getting hurt.
No.
So what the fuck are they doing?
They're locking this guy in jail.
That's,
this is crazy.
Why isn't everybody up in arms until I saw one of his movies.
Exactly.
I was going to say,
don't you know dude,
I've actually talked to porn stars about him,
like many porn stars about him and they all say the exact same thing.
Good.
I fucking hate that guy.
That guy needs to rot in hell.
Every like,
I mean,
I've literally talked about it maybe to 10 porn stars.
I lost him.
What
he was doing to this chick.
He was fucking this girl's mouth and pissing in her mouth and he kept doing it
and it was really disturbing.
He would like shove his dick in her mouth that she would be like in pain and
gagging and then he would start pissing in it and he would make her talk while
he was pissing in her mouth.
I mean,
I dunno how he must've just drank water all day for this,
this scene.
And I don't know how he's pissing with a hard on either,
but he's doing it,
you know,
I guess I guess he just drank so much that he has to pass and he took so much
Viagara that is Dick won't go down and so he's fucking this girl's mouth and
it's like so sadistic.
It was so disturbing to watch.
It was like that someone would do this,
you know,
to some other human being.
And like before that he's like teasing her and playing around with her and then
it like,
you know,
it escalates as he's doing shit to her to this point where he's fucking her
mouth and pissing in it.
I'm like,
whoa.
I was listening to the Howard Stern show and they said that,
I don't know if this is,
this is actually a scene,
but that guy sal was saying that there was one where um,
this guy pried open this chick's butthole Max hardcore did,
and then he pissed in her butthole while he pried it open with like a,
you know,
an a medical instrument and then he attached a straw to her butthole and made
her drink his piss at of her butthole.
Ah,
yeah.
Yeah.
Dad fucking dude should probably be in jail.
What could shit right.
Don't you think?
I mean that's,
that's not a healthy human being.
Yeah.
That's not good.
It's not good to have that guy around.
No,
that's scary man.
Yeah.
[inaudible] no one else is scary that somebody likes that shit.
No doubt that there's actually a website,
there's so many fucking weird porn websites.
I forget the name of this one website I was shown the other day where it's just
this big fat guy and he just pays these porn stars to come over to his house and
just fucking hit him and shit on them and make them Joyce drink pee.
And then they'd give him blow jobs and fuck them though.
But I think it's like the gimp or some,
I forget what the website,
it's one of the most popular websites ever.
It's just this ugly,
nasty one of the most popular everyone.
I mean,
you know what I mean?
It's pretty fine.
Let's find it.
Good.
Going to hit Google.
Fuck.
This is all about if my baby's listening,
please texted me the name of that website.
Just um,
Joe,
why just Google it?
I don't know.
I don't,
you literally don't know some weird ass name.
Somebody in the chat,
I'll know the name of it.
It's like the,
the something,
the gimp or something the fuck.
I'll often use a fat guy and it's a super popular website.
Girls Shit all over him,
right?
Some dudes are into that and for whatever reason that does not disturb me.
I don't,
it doesn't bother me.
The guy wants to grow to shit on them.
You know?
It's like,
like when Jimmy Norton talks about like a girls pissing and how we'll tell him
that he talks about an opion Anthony,
how he'll tell a girl when she's gone to the bathroom,
don't call yourself,
let me clean you.
And after she pisses,
she comes over and sits on his face and he licks her pests.
The mini in it.
That's what it's going in the minion m I
and I own
[inaudible] dot com like men,
onion.com oh,
that's it.
Hi.
Yes,
I am over 18 oh my God.
What are we getting in to see?
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Yeah,
and it's,
this is a man in charge.
You're nobody until you've been fucked by him.
Oh my God.
And he's fat and disgusting.
Guys covered in shit.
He's got shit all over.
His face was his ass.
It's like Joey Diaz Times 50 if your sexual evil,
I guess his giant ass,
his mouth fucking this girl,
by the way.
It's sponsored by dog fark.com which I don't even want to lick on dog.
Fuck.
All right,
let's go back.
It's
sponsored by dog fart.com oh my God.
My opening up a new tab,
son.
What are you doing man?
Dog.
firt.com Doug,
why Inter here for Interracial Porn?
Oh,
isn't that dog farts?
It's just black guys.
Fucking sad.
Girls here are so
the numbers are for porn stars.
Now that there's all this internet porn and girls can like do shit out of their
house,
the numbers have to be much,
much higher than they were like say in the heyday of the eight.
That's what it all is going towards.
I,
I heard from a big company that they were saying like how it's dead.
Dvds are dead.
They are man,
the Internet,
the Internet killed music.
Right?
If the Internet killed the music business,
not killed it,
but completely changed the whole dynamic of it.
Artists make the most money now off of their live performances.
That's where they make the majority of their money,
except for iTunes.
They make money off of iTunes.
But if it did that for,
for the fucking music businessman,
what is it gonna do for the porn business?
This is going to crush it because nobody wants to admit they're buying porn.
And when you could just go to Ustream or go to youporn or any of those sites in
it
instantly get something to jerk off to.
Why don't you go to a store?
I guess the only thing that's popular right now is like things like,
uh,
you know,
like the Cosby show porn,
you to heritage heritage and stuff or comedy stuff.
You know,
one of the dudes is in that and the dude,
it's also in the ATM thing is uh,
this guy Tyler night.
And I don't want to say his real name cause I don't know if he likes to be an
undercover,
but he's uh,
a buddy of mine,
he a trains it a Eddie school.
Yeah,
it does Jujitsu at legends.
Really Nice Guy.
Like super friendly and a really good writer.
He's a,
he,
he writes like a,
like nonfiction.
Like he writes like some hilarious stories about the porn business.
I forget what is,
uh,
if you just find Tyler night blog,
I bet you could find it online.
But he's a really talented writer and he's kind of really funny story about
doing an anal scene with a chick and,
and,
and he's got shit on his deck and he's trying to stay hard.
And it's really funny.
It's like really well written and intelligent and really funny.
But he's in a,
he's in both those,
he's in the 18 one that comes out.
He plays Ba,
he pays the Mr t character.
Uh,
but,
oh,
what is this?
We're looking at the minion again.
Okay.
This is not,
this guy's pretty smart though because I mean,
look,
he's,
he's fucking pretty attractive girls here.
We'll listen dude.
The bottom line is there's a lot of dumb whores out there and I have to do is
give them money.
There's a lot of sad women out there.
You know,
there's a lot of people that suck and people that suck raise kids that suck,
you know,
or people that suck do a shitty job of raising kids.
And they raised fucked up kids,
you know,
and then these fucked up kids get to a situation where they need a lot of money
and they don't have it.
And someone comes along and says,
Hey,
do you want to fuck this fat guy in the Internet?
And no one's gonna see it and next thing you know they'll doing it and they have
that sad look on their face.
I don't mind porn when the girl seems like she's into it,
but there's nothing sadder than watching a porn where it girls like reluctantly
sucking a dick and you can tell like she really doesn't want to be there and
she's giving off that energy.
Well most of them don't.
Most of it.
It's all fake.
Most girls don't come a the in porn
movies and stuff like that.
This seems like that.
Oh yeah,
of course.
Right.
What do you think the odds are?
Not many.
Like,
like there's a few girls where you can go,
oh that girl legit,
but for the most part,
from what I understand is a lie.
Don't just do it and it's almost fake.
And they,
there's like,
there's even like parts where like,
uh,
they're getting sprayed to make it look more wetter,
you know,
in there they're stopping the cam camera,
changing the camera around and you know,
it's like all,
you know,
it's not what it is.
I was calling about the Max hardcore thing that bugs me to get back to that.
It is disturbing all the shit this God does.
It's really disturbing because it's like sadistic and evil.
It's almost like a snuff porn,
but you know,
you're killing her dignity for life instead of killing her life.
You know,
there's like when when someone does a porn,
like say if you date a girl and she used to do porn,
oh you know,
I was young,
I got hooked on Coke and next thing I'm doing porn.
Who Cares?
What's the big deal?
You know,
it's like,
well we have,
we fuck if you,
you know,
you fuck on cameras that make you any different.
It's really,
it's no big deal.
But that's not porn.
That's like humiliation,
like sadistic type shit.
Like somebody didn't just fuck your girl.
He held her ass hole open,
pissed in it,
and then made her drink out of her asshole.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Well,
you know what I'm saying?
Like that guy,
he took a piece of our humanity.
She will always be humiliated by that experience.
That's always going to fuck with her head.
You know?
It's like he killed a little bit of her.
It's really like what he did was like,
I mean even if it's,
even if it's consensual,
you know,
to still to put that shit on a video,
it's,
if it's one thing of a chick likes to get pissing her ass and she's crazy,
but really how many girls want that on the Internet?
How many girls want that on a DVD?
Is it possible?
Is it even possible?
And that's what you're into.
I mean,
could you be me ever heard that argument that the,
I've,
I've always heard there's always like one or two girls they'll bring up that's
like comes from a healthy household and you know,
she does hardcore porn just because she's into it.
That's what she likes and she doesn't have any problems at all.
I've heard that pitched before and they always pretend the girls really smart
and she reads a lot of books.
[inaudible] what happened?
I don't know what happened.
Why is that guy fucking your asshole and then shoving in your mouth until you
gag and then stuffing it back in your ass on slapping you in the face and then
slapping you in the face with his Dick and then making you go while he's fucking
your mouth is,
is that,
is this all fun cause it's all what you were,
well I guess we want to do in life.
What is that?
I guess what it also is is that,
you know,
we're born thinking that we have to wear clothes were born right in that you're
not supposed to look at my butthole.
They were born thing that you're not,
you know,
sex is supposed to be a private thing and I guess it's just like anything else.
Like you know you just born into growing up that way.
But sometimes you,
you know,
if you think
that's a side effect of moving to climates that aren't like the jungle,
I don't have no idea what that think about this human being started out now for
car.
Right.
And even though Africa's dangerous as fuck,
and there's,
you know,
all sorts of shit that could bite you and kill you.
There's ants that eat elephants,
bro.
There's these fucking ants.
You know the massive ants I found this on.
Oh my God.
facts.com I think it is.
Whatever it is.
It's on Twitter.
Oh God.
Facts.
The mass of ants in this world,
like the weight of all the ants in the world is roughly the same as the weight
of all the people in the world.
Hmm.
What the fuck?
Yes.
That's how many answers are too.
They're everywhere.
These fucks and they are the number one killers in the world in Africa.
They're the number one killers and
it's,
whoa,
wait,
wait.
So you're saying if you took all the ants and then wait and wait,
it's all the people on the road.
The ants would way more.
Yes.
I read this on the Internet,
it must be true.
You know what?
That is the most untrue thing ever.
Let's find out.
It might be true.
Oh my God,
Google.
Let's Google this.
This is where in 2010 we should not be having a conversation where we were like
in 1993 okay,
you hit,
you hit fucking tab t go ahead gun there.
But the problem with [inaudible] suffer news.
That is what?
Insanely impossible.
Well,
how's it insanely impossible cause you can take,
well come on man.
Come on man.
Type Shit in.
You don't know that.
That's way more people butthole.
No,
don't tell [inaudible] hold on.
Why don't you just write,
did they answer in the road way more than all the people in the road.
Okay,
here we answer.
No.
Okay.
answers.com answers.com they don't weigh more.
Do all the ants in then spent way more than what people are up the answer.
That's the wrong question.
Cause I said roughly the same.
Oh,
roughly the same.
What I said is that the weight of ants and what is the sense in the world they
way an average of 0.01 Jesus.
Dude,
that's the weight of an aunt.
That's so stupid to answer way more than people you.
You asked the wrong God damn question.
No,
that's not what you want either more than the number of the Jesus Christ.
The ants way more than people know.
Does put put the put in the,
in the Google search,
right?
Put does the total mass is the total total mass of ants.
Ants on earth,
on earth way the same or roughly
who taught you how to Google?
I just how I do it,
but mom [inaudible] way the same as the total mass of humans.
Not the same.
The has an h in it.
So same
as the total mass of humans.
Mass.
Uh,
yeah man.
Holy Shit.
How much does the Earth Way,
why?
You know what your Google skills,
okay.
Oh wait.
Of all the ants in the world versus weight of all the humans in the world and
rural versus humans.
Here we go.
I'll try that one.
Facts about ants as compared to humans?
No.
Okay.
Listen,
we're not going to find this out that quickly and still be entertaining on the
radio.
Wait of all the ants in the roads combined is much lighter than the weight of
all animals combined.
The answer,
the combined weight of all the ants in the road,
it's approximately the same or greater than the combined weight of all human
beings.
There you go.
[inaudible] dot com so we got an affirmative
that that is it.
I do not believe it.
You don't believe it will?
I believe it because you think about how many more,
you know,
answer everywhere,
dude.
I mean the,
they literally are everywhere.
Everywhere there's dirt,
there's ants.
Yeah,
but would you,
if you had a truck like a bulldozer and a huge bulldozer filled to the top of
ants,
just,
I mean packed of ants and all those aunts fell on you,
do you think you'd just be like,
oh,
gross.
Or do you think by I'm dead,
I'm,
you'd be dead?
What kind of questions you're asking.
Really?
Yeah,
Dude.
No,
I mean,
just from the impact of them.
Yeah,
they would crush her.
They'll kill you.
Yeah,
I think,
I think there's way more ants in your thinking,
I think.
I think you're wrong.
I think they're everywhere,
dude.
Look,
that's,
we just found out on answers.com it must be true,
right?
We don't know if it's true or not,
but that's a problem at the Internet.
Look,
but the point is in,
in Africa,
answer a huge,
huge fucking problem.
This is getting back to the original thought.
The point is in Africa,
aunts kill everything dude.
They kill elephants.
They crawl up elephant's legs,
they get in their ear and they start eating them alive from the fucking ear and
they have swarms of them that do it in the ants can't.
The elephants can't stop them.
There's nothing they can do.
You can't shake them off and they get eaten alive.
Like the ants kill more things in Africa than any other animal.
They kill everything there.
They're fucking scary shit.
And these people that live in Africa or running around naked,
the run around naked without it.
We would have hazard suits on,
we would have armor,
you know,
in 2010 if we lived in Africa,
if you had to live in a part of the world where the ants,
one ant bites you and it sends a signal to all his buddies.
I found something we can eat and they all fucking swarm on you and there's no
way you can stop them cause there's trillions of them and they're climbing up
your legs and eat in your asshole alive.
How would you live in a place like that?
You would have some sort of a mesh suit that was impenetrable.
It would be sprayed with toxins on the outside.
You have a fucking helmet on,
like you're on Mars.
That's how he'd walk around.
Yes.
Crazy about insects and stuff like that is that the other day I was just laying
in bed in this huge fucking spider,
just as crawling on my bed and it had like a red stripe on it and it just looked
like death spider.
And I'm just like,
you know,
if I was not awake or if I was sleeping and I happened to rollover and this guy
bit me,
would I die?
Is that how
right.
You know that Brown recluse is a scary motherfucker.
Have you ever seen pictures of people that got bitten by a brown recluse,
like burns,
like folds through you?
Especially if you don't get it taken care of like right away,
like eight to hold to your fucking body.
It's terrifying.
Shit man.
So my point is these people live in Africa.
This is where like humanity supposedly was created or a evolved,
I mean our roots,
all our roots of all human beings go back to Africa and in Africa is hot as fuck
and they're all naked.
So do you think that like when these people branched out to climates that they
couldn't control and they had to change their environment rather than they
couldn't live in,
um,
uh,
without doing something,
without trying to control their temperature,
without covering themselves and building houses that are sheltered and insulated
and starting fires and stuff,
all this stuff they didn't have to do in Africa.
Then they started having to wear clothes and when they started wearing clothes,
then it wasn't like a common thing to see someone's genitals.
It was like very rare.
Like you gotta get this bitch out of his fucking first.
I don't,
I get this pitch out of these first,
it's zero degrees out.
Okay.
You don't even have a fucking house to live in.
You live in,
in a hole in the snow and you're trying to get laid and you've got to try and
get this chicken out of it for,
you know,
what the fuck you gonna do,
man.
It's a grind,
you know?
So that's when people became fucked up sexually because like,
you know,
back then they still probably didn't even have a fucking language.
So they,
you know,
they couldn't say,
listen,
how about I eat your pussy?
It's like my it,
let's have a party.
You know?
They couldn't even like talk their way into it because they probably,
when they first started doing that and moving to other climates,
they probably didn't even have a language yet.
They're just grunting.
It's certain Shit,
you know?
So they,
they just,
they just got all fucked up about sex because they couldn't fuck anymore.
Like they used to in the jungle and the jungle,
they were naked.
They would get horny and they just fuck.
But now it's like,
it becomes a huge hassle because why?
It's often used to hide when you live in a jungle.
Yeah.
People want you to have sex.
Nobody cares.
That's how monkeys are monkeys.
Fuck right in front of everybody.
They don't worry about shit.
I saw some good monkey sex the last week when I was at the zoo.
Yeah.
Monkeys,
you fuck right in front of whole crowds of people.
They like it.
Well,
you know,
why not?
Why wouldn't they?
What do you do?
You give a shit.
You do other things that are pleasurable in front of people,
right.
You know,
you get a massage in front of people.
It doesn't bother you that much.
Right.
You know,
you know,
thinking about if you lie on your back and you know,
you could be in a park and someone's got awesome massages,
they give out the park like,
oh,
we do deep tissue.
It's only 10 bucks,
like damn pen box.
Oh I'm gonna get a massage and you'll lie face down on the massage table and let
people rub you in front of people.
But if you know,
she was given head,
you know,
or hand jobs,
just hand jobs,
you know,
you don't want anybody to see your,
your calm come out.
He couldn't just sit there with all those people at the park and just let
someone jerk you off.
You know,
you wouldn't enjoy it.
Do you think we're going to go back to that letting like it seems like you know
the,
you know,
the more that we're getting used to sacs in the more Regan regained and used to
seeing girls butt holes and stuff like that because of the Internet and stuff.
You think we're going to get back to the state if soon.
We're all just going to be having orgies all over the place and kids are gonna
be smoking cigarettes.
The no,
the cigarettes are definitely know.
I don't know.
It's possible we'd have to get past a lot of hurdles.
You know,
I think it's pretty obvious that if you look at human sexuality,
especially the way we treat sex in America,
you know,
we're,
we're very,
very uptight about it.
And I think that one of the reasons why we're very,
very uptight about it is because we're imbalanced.
You know,
we're in imbalanced by the fact that we grew up and moved to new environments
and invented clothes.
You know,
inventing close allowed us to live in a bunch of different places,
but it also allowed us to,
we fucked up the natural sexual cycle.
You know,
the natural,
a way of looking at each other and,
and behaving.
When you add suppression to anything,
be the reason why priests are fucked up.
It's not just because religion is ridiculous and to live your whole life by some
shit that was written thousands of years ago.
That makes no sense.
That's ridiculous.
And abstaining from sex is ridiculous.
All that stuff is completely ridiculous.
But the real,
real problem with being a priest,
one of reasons why they're so
fucked up is because there's a massive amount of suppression about your own
natural drives,
your all natural things.
There's a natural cycle living inside of your body,
you know,
or,
or operating your body rather.
And it's existed for millions of years and it's the reason why human beings
procreate and it's the reason why animals procreate.
And when you put a stopper to that shit and you label all that shit is evil and
bad,
you're going to create issues.
And just just interrupting the natural cycle of things.
It's like you're putting on the brakes of like something that you can't control
your,
you putting on the brakes for something that you're not supposed to control.
It's supposed to be a natural part of your life.
You know?
It's one of the things that makes us,
you know,
and this is what I've found from having kids.
One of the things that makes you a different person,
one of the things that takes you to another place is the development of other
new human beings.
It's like you,
you lose a lot of your selfless selfishness.
And I think that that's a natural part of a progression as a human being.
And so that shit doesn't exist for priests and it doesn't really exist for us.
If we,
if we wear clothes,
you know,
if we were close and cover each other up and all suppressed about sex and
worried about it,
I mean eventually you're going to realize that a certain point in your life
you're gonna be like,
fuck,
what did I waste all this time tweaking about sex for,
you know,
what is it?
It's just two people touch on their buys together and enjoying it.
You know?
Why is it such a fucking a big Goddamn deal to people?
What is it?
Well,
it's because we,
we suppress it because we've covered up,
that's why magazine ads at show girls in bikinis,
just like the pussy is almost there.
It's like you can almost see it's so attractive to sell cars or self fucking
water.
You could tell anything with pussy.
You know,
just a girl in a little wet bikini come out of the water,
bending over to pick up her sunglasses.
She's on her knees.
She'd turn around and look towards the camera.
Oh,
you might just start checking off right now.
And whenever,
fuck she's selling gum.
What did she sell in breath wash?
What'd she selling?
You know,
sunscreen.
I'll buy it.
I'll think of that hot bitch and I'll buy their product.
Yeah.
I just saw as sex in the city too.
I was forced to go sound dare you forced to go see that,
you know,
I mean I got,
I got rewarded nicely.
Dang backwards.
Calgary.
A couple other things.
It was awesome.
But uh,
it's funny how they,
they,
they took place in Abi Dhabi and you had been there?
Yeah,
but to buy right?
To buy,
I think it's to buy.
Oh,
Dubai.
Yeah,
I thought it was Abu Dhabi.
Dubai.
Dubai is supposedly the,
like the big attraction over the Middle East.
That's where everybody goes to [inaudible] he's a lot like it.
But Dubai is the more popular,
no,
no.
I think that's what the whole point in the movie was.
Cause they talk about how the buy is like popular and trying to build up Abi
Dhabi.
They talk.
Oh okay.
So am I arguing about the pro,
the plot and premise of a fucking sex and the city movie or you're acting like
you don't know.
And so one thing,
one thing off the bat,
it's amazing how much that plays some of like periods in there.
Like you know that smell that tampon smelled like,
that's kind of like a flower perfume smell that whiffed everywhere combined with
popcorn.
It was the most disgusting smell ever.
It was pretty bad.
But anyway,
how many chicks go to sea sex in the city?
Oh crazy.
I'll put how many of them are like those girls.
Oh
did,
they were all taken the girls next to us.
We're taking pictures of their shoes together while we're waiting for the
previews.
They were like,
Dang,
she used together.
Let's take a picture on my Twitter,
our shoes.
You know what the thing knows?
Chicks are so happy about that shit.
Oh you gotta love that Shit.
Yeah it is.
It's so funny because like,
like in it every time,
like Carrie,
I mean,
I mean the,
the main character.
Yeah,
she would.
Yeah.
What was the test?
You knew who it was?
Well,
I've seen the show care yet.
Brian cows on it once I washed it.
Oh yeah,
that was great.
I think I've watched it a couple times,
but every time like she would like wear a new outfit or the x,
she would show her closet.
That was a big thing when they showed her closet again,
they were like,
oh,
the whole crowd together.
It was awesome.
It was great.
A bunch of aliens.
Oh you're around a bunch of checks.
That's a hot aliens,
aliens.
And the more you get to know them,
the more you realize how many of them I like that.
And the ones that aren't like that are really just pretending for us.
[inaudible] you know.
But by the way,
that movie though was,
it was kind of,
I don't know,
I wouldn't say racist,
but it was kind of weird how they,
they,
they were talking about the Abu Dhabi thing where they can even allowed to like
hold hands in public or to kiss in public and stuff.
And it was like this tension throughout the movie about that.
Then I don't want to give it away to all the ladies.
So you guys know.
Spoiler,
spoiler alert.
Uh,
so in your near the end of the movie,
uh,
they just,
one of the characters just went off like I liked the fuck.
I am like throwing condoms everywhere.
I like the older check.
Yeah.
The older chick.
In front of everyone.
Abi Dhabi.
Dude.
They would lock her in a hole in the dirt so fast.
Oh,
I know.
I know they would,
they would put her in jail.
They put a couple in jail for kissing on the beach there.
Yeah.
That was a part in the movie too.
They were kissing on the beach and she got locked up and was thrown out there.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's based on
real life.
They actually did that to a woman or a woman and a man,
uh,
in Dubai for making out there were a couple and they're making,
I mean,
I don't know what they were doing.
They might've been like fingering each other or something,
you know,
it might have been calling it making out,
but it got a little crazy.
But apparently it's,
you know,
it's super,
super illegal over there.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
It's crazy.
It's not a bad movie.
Jail.
I loved it.
Huh?
It's better than the first one.
I haven't seen either one of them and I only intend to,
how dare you.
I'm keeping my balls and tax.
So you got to do things like that.
No,
I would do it.
I would do it if it was like a date night or something stupid like that,
I would do it just cause I would think it was ridiculous and I probably get some
material out of it.
All that great sex I got in response for doing that was worth every penny.
Shouldn't have to barter for sex side.
I know things that go take that pussy chores yet.
I imagine being able to take it wherever you want to.
Like we're at toys or run shit.
The one two should be able to anyway.
Fuck you.
I think you could.
You just gotta force it on her.
Not forcing our physically.
Just bring up the idea with urgency like you like with real a real sense focus
and urgency.
We're not talking right here.
We're just talking like a lot of,
a lot of energy,
you know,
and just get excited about I one.
Fuck you right now.
Right here.
Shop,
shop please pass down.
What?
No,
you can't shut up.
Let me,
I'm just going to stick it in.
I'm just gonna stick it in.
You're not even hard feeling them hard.
Oh my God.
You are art.
Yeah.
Shop shop.
Believe his town.
This camera's,
who cares?
They got a photo.
Video me fucking you real quick.
All right.
I'm gonna stop right now.
You could do that dude.
Don't look at me when you do that shit.
I'm just trying to make Brian uncomfortable.
[inaudible] it's so creepy,
dude.
There's nothing more fun though than the beginning of a relationship when you
just get comfortable with each other.
Like you haven't gotten sick of fucking each other yet and you're just getting
comfortable with each other and you're starting to have fun.
You know,
you're starting to talk dirty to each other.
I starting to get excited.
He sent each other some nasty texts and shit like that.
Those are the good days.
There's a different level of excitement and really it's just your body trying to
ensure that you breed with this person.
Really.
It's just a bunch of chemicals flowing through your brain that your body is
trying to give you to ensure that you breed.
It's incredible,
man.
It's incredible that they haven't figured out how to pocket.
That's to how the pill it package it,
you know,
put that shit in a pill form.
He takes something that makes you feel like when you're,
you're horny and,
and love,
you know that feeling when you want to fuck her.
And she went to fuck you and you can't wait to see her.
And as soon as you see her,
you get excited and you,
you,
you're and you feel good.
You get all this big charge of energy.
We don't even realize what we're doing.
You know,
we think,
wow,
I just admit of new relationship.
Things are fun.
When it's new,
that's not what it is.
You're getting all these extra chemicals because your brain is trying to ensure
that you make with this freak.
That's what it is.
Your brain is getting all this extra juice.
Why haven't they figured out how a package that I don't know,
but they need to,
dude,
how good would the world be?
There's your antidepressants.
You know how come dudes that are in depressed always in Sucky,
sucky relationships are sucky situations.
Nobody's depressed in an awesome relationship when everything's going great,
because that's your little juice.
That's,
that's where your antidepressants are coming from.
We're all junkies for brain chemicals.
You know what I'm saying,
son doing that.
What you're saying,
did you see that fucking hole in the ground in Guatemala?
Boy,
what dude?
My friend.
Listen,
you gotta look at the hole in the ground and Guatemala.
Is it the sinkhole?
Oh,
Jesus.
Google right now,
Guatemala sinkhole and be prepared to freak out and call fake.
You're going to freak out and call fake.
I might type in Guacamole sinkhole and see if this is a glock.
That's it.
See,
see,
it's the fucking second one.
Look No.
Go Guatemala,
Guatemala,
dummy.
Look at that.
Look when you watching you,
you age.
Do you a lie?
See who that see sinkhole right away.
It's the first search.
Look at Dow.
Do.
Look how deep that fucking thing is.
It's crazy.
It's like Oh hell.
Up out of nowhere and swallowed a building that's swallowed a whole building.
Easy Dude.
There's so many pictures of it online.
If you haven't seen it,
ladies and gentlemen,
Google,
you don't even just type in Google Eua,
G U A and it'll Guatemala sinkhole will be the first search or the second search
option.
It's incredible.
It is literally a perfect circle and it's huge.
It's gigantic and it's in the middle of this intersection and ate a whole house.
The house just fell down and disappeared and it's super,
super deep.
The image that we're looking at.
There's a helicopter shadow on the wall of the,
uh,
of the,
of the circle.
But it's,
it's giant.
It's like a half a block wide
it.
Alright.
You know what it reminds me of immediately is they like something from district
nine.
Yeah.
It doesn't even look real.
It's like,
well how is that happening?
How is,
how have we never seen anything even remotely that crazy before?
And how often could that happen?
Is it possible that can happen in Los Angeles?
I mean,
I guess it has to be running water.
We don't really have running water here.
How many cities do it says after a devastating tropical storm?
So it was,
it just water,
the water ran through and somehow or another created a giant spherical hole.
It's like a,
it's like a tube.
It looks like somebody took an apple core to the world.
Wow.
I mean it doesn't look natural,
right?
It looks like something somebody created Guatemala stink whole asshole.
I just wanna see if it brings up,
yep.
Bright point.
Cool.
Look,
somebody's tagged their photo Guatemala sinkhole.
And if you just type an asshole,
it comes up.
Yeah.
And it says,
look,
when you click on it,
it gives you some sort of a warning.
Yeah.
Visiting this site may harm your computer.
Hilarious.
These guys that are doing these hacks and shit,
like that kind of stuff.
Who is that?
Is it Chinese or Russian?
It's just something that occurs all over the world.
Nigeria.
Yeah.
Cause they always tag.
They always name it to a country.
Yeah.
If you just Google switched.
From a Microsoft operating systems,
they made an announcement that they're going to merge to a using a Linux and
using Mac because uh,
the Chinese,
uh,
fellows hacked them and fucked with their whole website and they say there's too
many security issues.
Yeah.
And Windows.
Why did you hear it happening here?
Any of that?
Steve jobs talk the other day.
He did this long talk at all things digital 2010.
No,
he was talking about through everything.
Uh,
if you go to Gizmodo GIC,
that's where I saw this whole,
the sinkhole.
Real Gizmodo too.
Yeah.
He,
uh,
there's always videos or are up there.
And I,
it's kind of interesting hearing like a really intelligent person talk about the
future of the Internet and stuff.
It's really interesting,
you know,
I agree with him on a lot of things,
but a lot of things I agree with his,
his detractors when it comes to open source things and it comes to,
uh,
you know,
allowing people to create more applications and have things more,
more open for the Mac and you know,
clones and things,
things of that nature.
The ability to just,
by the operating system,
why do you have to buy the hardware and the operating system?
You know,
that's kind of,
I agree with that to a certain extent.
But I also agree with like lookout when he controls everything.
Look how great everything works,
you know,
when you,
yeah,
exactly.
I mean,
it's like,
it's definitely cheaper to go to a store and buy,
you know,
a hard drive and buy a motherboard and all that shit and put together your own
box.
It's way cheaper.
I've done it a couple of times.
It's fun too,
but you're going to have all sorts of issues.
The sound cards,
not gonna want to work with tr tr certain motherboard that you have.
It's going to fuck up the video card fucks up.
You got to replace things.
You can't get the right drivers cause you got to do a lot of tweaking.
A lot of shit,
you know,
with a Mac.
All you have to just turn it on,
you know?
That's why people don't like it.
It's people who could forgive.
Will you Fergie forgive.
No Idiots fucking Mac losers.
Just cause you don't know how to work at PC.
I've never got a virus.
Okay.
I've been using a PC for 10 years.
I've never got a virus.
Yeah,
I started,
I started with a windows 98 okay.
And then they'll go off on you and they'll let you know they've never got a
virus.
You know why?
Well,
I scan,
I'm not stupid.
I don't click random blinks,
you know?
Yeah.
You know all these people,
if they had a Mac laptop I think,
and a windows laptop,
I think if they have both of them don't end up using the Mac laptop after
awhile.
Well it becomes a team thing.
We've discussed this before,
it becomes a,
you know,
a fucking Raiders versus the dolphins.
You know,
just people get crazy about teams and they get on team windows.
They never want to admit that they made horrible mistakes.
You know,
I was watching this documentary,
speaking of that on this Graham Hancock interview and I put it on my message
board.
You know,
Graham Hancock says no,
Graham Hancock is the guy that,
uh,
he's this his duty wrote fingerprints of the Gods and uh,
he's done a bunch of underwater dives where he's found all this evidence of
previous civilizations.
Pretty,
pretty interesting shit man.
But one of the things in the videos,
they talk about the Sphinx.
You know,
there's a whole bunch of geologists led by this Guy Ron shock at a Boston
University that believed that the Sphinx is way,
way older than conventional Egyptologists have dated it.
And they've dated it to 2,500 BC.
And he says it's way older than that because he shows the geologist shows all
this water erosion,
all of the Sphinx.
And he said,
see this,
what you're looking at is clearly water erosion from thousands of years of
rainfall.
Well,
the last time there was rain fall in that area of the world was 7,000 BC.
So you're looking at something that like,
it's gotta be a couple thousand years older than that because a couple thousand
years of rainfall.
So you're talking about like at least 9,000 BC,
which is,
you know,
that's like you're talking about like 7,000 years older than they think it is.
That's longer between them and the age of the roof.
The true age of the construction is spanx than it is between them and us.
I mean,
when you really put it into perspective,
it's 2000 years longer than the distance between the pharaohs of like two tongue
comment and us.
I mean,
that's pretty nutty shit when you think about it.
Well,
he brought all this geological evidence to these conventional a Egyptologists
and archeologists and they wanted to dismiss it right away.
They wanted to say,
well,
this doesn't make no,
you,
you have no evidence of a culture that could build this.
You know?
So where's your evidence?
Show me some.
Show me something that it comes from this area and so they say,
well,
we're showing you all that would be left.
We're showing you some construction.
There's not 10,000 years from now,
there's,
there's not going to be anything of us.
You know the,
the,
you ever seen the pictures of Detroit where you see Detroit getting swallowed up
by the city?
Like there's abandoned houses in Detroit where trees are grown out of the middle
of the house.
It's crazy.
The earth is slowly starting to eat up all these abandoned buildings.
That's awesome.
There's a site that's dedicated to that in the Soviet Union to we're up like
total towns had been like evacuated and left where trees are just like growing
through houses now.
They just,
nature starts to retake things.
Well he,
he brought all this stuff to these Egyptologists and they just dug their hand
head in the sand.
They didn't want to see the truth.
They didn't want to,
they didn't want to admit that they have been,
you know,
doing things or teaching things that were not totally correct or wasn't the full
picture of the earth.
And it's really crazy shit because this guy proposes that things like this
Guatemala Sinkhole,
like that's a little tiny one that's a little,
nothing happened.
You know,
a little thing opened up in a house,
fell through.
But there's a bunch of different things that the earth can do like that.
There's a bunch of different really insane thing like super volcanoes or you
know,
tsunamis.
There's a m in the Canary Islands,
there's a volcanic rock,
there's like a volcanic mountain sign that they know eventually it's going to
break off.
They know it's going to break off and slide into the ocean.
And when it does,
they think that it's going to create a tsunami that will cover the entire
eastern seaboard of the United States of America.
Like miles in kills everyone.
Everyone's fucked.
I mean,
there's so much rock there and there's a bunch of evidence that this kind of
shit has happened in the past.
There's going to be some other underwater earthquake,
it's going to break off and it's going to head towards the United States at 500
feet high and a fucking hundred and 50 miles an hour and just smush everything.
Wow.
Do probably more than 150 miles now.
I just pulled that number out of my ass.
How do you like that?
Okay.
Have you just them,
have you been following that Foxcom Shit,
dude,
you turned me on to that.
And for the folks out there listening that don't know about this,
Foxconn is a company,
well,
why don't you describe it?
Foxconn is like a huge company and uh,
was it China?
Uh,
that,
that makes like most of the technology,
uh,
like,
you know,
like the build,
like Nintendo's,
they build like psps that build apple computers.
They build,
you know,
iPods and stuff.
They're just really cheap,
almost like slave labor,
but they're not.
Uh,
and I think they get paid what was that?
$130 a month or something like that.
And there's like tons and tons of workers.
But lately there's been all these suicides and it's almost daily.
If you follow gizmodo.com it's almost daily.
You'll see,
you know,
another suicide and another person jumps off a building.
I forget.
There's like been like 13 or something like that in the last this year or
something.
Well,
uh,
lately it's almost every day they'd been freaking out.
Like Nintendo's getting pissed and Steve Jobs has said he's going to get to the
bottom of it and figure out why all these people are committing suicide.
They had to sign a contract saying that you will not commit suicide.
And if you do,
they're not held responsible in any way.
So their families and stuff can't sue and stuff like that.
Then,
uh,
about four days ago or a week ago,
they raise the pay 20%.
They raised their whole entire pay 20% because they're trying to make everyone
happy and stuff.
Three days later they raised it to 30%.
That's how fucking crazy it's getting.
And then today they're scattered reports of a fire and they're like trying,
Foxcom is trying to keep this all hush hush.
But I guess there might be a dozen workers ever either injured or dead.
Uh,
and it's,
it's getting out of control.
I'm not really sure what the fuck's going on here,
but it's starting to get like,
all right,
there's something crazy going on in this factory that all these people are
killing themselves and that there's,
you know,
I mean,
hasn't there been video released of a worker's getting beaten?
Yeah.
That security guards are security guards from the plant.
There's a video of him them like beating up,
uh,
the workers and uh,
you know,
and it's crazy when you think about it,
cause you were saying something about this earlier,
like how we expect like,
you know,
iPhones to be a certain price and iPods to be a certain price and the only way
that they're,
that certain prices because of these workers,
this slave labor,
right?
Yeah.
So they make about,
you said about a hundred dollars a month.
$130 a month is what I heard that they start at a pay wise and they live there
and I,
yeah,
it happened when it gets kind of like,
it's kind of like a community,
like you live there like a,
like a dorm room almost or something like that or it's,
I don't quite get it.
So they sleep in like these dorms?
Yeah,
they live on,
on the,
on the factory.
Right.
And they make shit money and they probably never get to leave.
Do they even get days off?
Uh,
I,
I don't know.
I heard that they were pretty much work.
I'm nonstop day and night and they signed something in the contract saying that
they're going to be working overtime and stuff like that.
And I don't know,
but that's the only way.
It's the only way you're going to get all these Goddamn iPhones for 500 bucks.
I mean,
that's,
uh,
that things should be like probably like $2,000,
you know,
if you had like workers that were paid correctly.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean,
how much more money would it cost?
Labor's a big part of the operations for any big business like that.
Right?
Yeah.
But you know,
it's,
it's funny cause like Steve Jobs was saying,
you know,
well look how many,
uh,
Walmart workers there are in the United States,
you know,
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of people and stuff like that.
And you know,
there's people you know,
dying,
you know,
kick suiciding all the time that worked for Walmart,
you know?
Yeah.
But that's a poor analogy.
It's a poor analogy because you don't see people jumping off the top of
Walmart's buildings that,
you know,
you don't see that in the news.
Another Walmart.
What are dead,
you know?
Well not only that,
it's voluntary.
Yeah.
You could call Walmart tomorrow and go suck my dick or quit.
Right.
And they'll go,
who cares?
You know,
they're not gonna come to your house and beat you up.
they're not going to wake you out of bed and stun you or something,
you know,
I don't know what they're doing people,
I'm just making shit up.
It's crazy.
Cause all the photos.
If you,
again,
the website's gives Giz,
m o,
d o Gizmodo,
and just type in Foxconn or just look through it.
You'll see it.
It's like on that first couple of pages.
But look at all the employees.
You just feel so it's so depressing.
Very depressing.
It looks like almost like a jail.
Yeah,
it does.
Another Fox common employee dies after working 34 hours straight.
This just happened today,
I guess.
Oh my God.
Yep.
June 2nd.
This 28 year old man,
20 year old man married his wife for only three months ago.
Died from exhaustion.
Oh my God.
34 hours.
Okay.
It says that's what his family is claiming anyway.
Yeah.
No official statement that's been issued.
Well,
you know what,
I believe it.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
look,
it's possible.
Um,
uh,
I wouldn't be surprised,
you know,
I mean,
it saddens you,
but it doesn't surprise you.
You know,
it's,
uh,
it's really a sick thing,
you know,
that we have,
um,
this,
uh,
this desire in this country to have new things.
And I mean,
it's not,
that's not the sick part of it,
but the sick part of it is the only way to get these iPhones for 500 bucks is
someone has to suffer.
Someone has to do something that they don't want to do.
There's only one reason why companies move their factories to Guatemala or all
these impoverished places,
and they say,
look,
we're helping these people.
It's because they're taking advantage of a different situation.
They're taking advantage of a different economic situation at different
situations,
far as resources.
You know,
if you go to China and there's a fucking billion people,
all right,
they've got to do something.
You know,
when there's a billion fucking people,
you're going to have a lot of people that are just laying around that needs
something to do.
You know,
they have to figure out a way to survive.
They have to figure out a way to feed themselves.
You know what's weird is that when I've talked about this last week,
it was 12 people and I just read to hear that since last podcast a week ago,
that number is now 16 whoa.
And they,
so fifth,
uh,
suicides have reached 15 potential 16 spotted on the roof right now.
So they're actually writing this article and go,
wait and wait,
and here's the 16th one on the roof right now.
So they're just jumping every day.
Yeah.
A couple of day,
someone's out there four and a week to two.
Uh,
I mean,
salary increases in a week to salary increases.
There's a fire and another person died today.
Well,
what good is having any money.
If you can't use it,
you can't even spend it,
you know,
pumping their salary up 30%.
It's not going to shit.
Yeah.
It doesn't mean amazing.
These people need back rubs and fless lights.
Yeah.
What does that mean?
They get 150 bucks a month?
I mean,
that's crazy.
That's a sick,
sick thing.
It's just,
it's fucking sad.
It's sad that this is the only way to do it.
And it's also sad that if these people weren't doing this,
if you talk about like third world countries or countries that are all fucked
up,
that you know,
uh,
the United States exploits or United States corporations rather exploiting.
And go over there and start businesses and w what would these people be doing if
the United States wasn't there?
That's the thing.
It's like,
why are they living so badly?
Why they saw impoverished?
Would it benefit us to have them rise up to our level?
Would it benefit us?
You know,
to instead of exporting them to go over there and educate these people and try
to get them to start producing their own,
you know,
democratic society with,
good businesses and trade goods and services and get everything to go pump in
and introduce them to new technology and shit.
Would it benefit us to have them or would they just become competition?
You know?
I mean,
why is it that the United States
corporations,
these big corporations just do that?
I mean,
they go over there and help these people a little bit to give them money and
shit and you know,
they give people jobs and solve them.
Some of them might be happy with that,
but for the most part they're taking advantage of people that are willing to
work for pennies on the dollar compared to Americans.
Right.
Would it benefit them to like really build up a country would have benefit the
United States if there was no third world,
you know?
Is that possible?
Is it possible that we're ever going to come to a time where there is no worry
about like there's no Mexico,
there's no place where you go,
where it sucks.
There's no place where you go,
where everything's,
you know all your fuck now.
No,
it's just getting worse.
I think it's just getting,
there's more places getting that you don't want to go to.
I'm just not,
you know what I mean?
It's getting worse and worse.
Right.
Is that possible to recover from though?
I don't.
I don't know.
What would it be like if instead of,
I mean this is all totally hypothetical,
but do you think it's possible as a human being to instead of doing what we're
doing,
you know,
certain corporations would go to different countries and exploit the people
instead of doing that?
What if they decided to try to,
as much as possible,
like on a whole,
instead of controlling the resources of the world,
we try to make everything a level.
We try to bring everybody up as far as like the,
you know,
the,
the quality of their society and the quality of their culture,
you know,
the quality of their,
their information and,
you know,
the Internet and all that shit and give it to everybody and try to pump them up.
Will that benefit us?
Would that benefit human beings as a whole?
They wouldn't it?
Yeah,
but no,
because then how the fuck you going to get an iPhone for 500 bucks?
You know,
because unless you've got a robot that knows how to make an iPhone swim,
I think [inaudible] slave laborers that are just going to die off because of
robots in factory lines or the housing complex.
I was going to die off because the robots do it.
Well,
I mean there's,
they're going to be factories to build robots,
I guess.
But,
uh,
you know,
like just factory,
like,
you know,
when you look at cars,
how cars are manufactured,
you know,
half of it's done by robots,
right?
The person who's willing to work for $100 a week,
it's probably way cheaper than a robot that's going to do his job.
So I think they're always going to have robots for certain things just because
you can get a lot of people that work fucking cheapest shit.
Robots are expensive,
dude.
Unless robot technology gets like super mainstream,
it's going to get mainstream and robots are going to be mainstreamed or I'm
already fucking,
I have an alarm clock that can watch movies on now.
You know,
it's,
you know,
it's the more to computers grow,
technology grows.
There's going to be more robots and the robots are definitely
calming,
but the world is going to be like your own house,
then we're one thing fucks up and the whole thing just goes to the Goddamn
Haywire.
Totally going to be like that is going to be like that.
Right?
Yeah,
absolutely.
That's the big,
there was,
yeah.
What there's a shit.
I don't know if we,
I don't know.
We did not talk about,
this I talked to about with a couple of long time ago in these podcasts,
I talked about how people are hacking.
How'd the idea that you could hack into somebody's car and like slam on the
brakes.
So actually there was a report a couple of weeks ago where people will actually
start doing that to onstar.
Where that you could,
they could hack into people's Onstar's and like stop their cars and there was
hackers,
I think Mexico,
Mexican gangs or something like that.
We're starting to do that where they're hacking into peoples onstar.
Uh,
and like fucking with your shit and finding out where they're at.
Finding,
yeah.
I guess Onstar has a security hole in it right now.
Oh my God,
I've never heard of that.
Yeah,
sure.
You better fucking Google this son.
I don't get sued.
No,
totally Google this onstar hack.
Yeah.
We need to find out the songs.
Onstar GPS Hakka Day.
Uh,
let's go to news onstar.
Yeah.
Modern automobile.
Super Vulnerable to hacking.
Researchers say
so.
It's not Mexicans.
I forget.
[inaudible] Mexicans all the time.
No,
but there was something,
yeah,
offend all the Mexicans out there.
We have Mexican listeners,
so people from Mexico.
Okay.
So I want you to be nice.
I got people from Mexico.
Okay.
So anyways,
yeah,
I guess whatever thing I saw was something about the Onstar had a security hole
in it and people were uh,
hackers tapping the ECU to kill engine brakes in more blah blah.
Here we go.
This is it auto blog.com.
Yeah.
But is that as Onstar and Ecu the same thing?
I don't think so.
Now they're starting to
moving into the age of connected vehicles.
The risk of rapidly increasing onstar already has the ability to remotely slow a
stolen car.
Ford is current.
Yeah,
I saw that in the ad for the new corvette.
There's a,
um,
I was looking at this,
uh,
this is a corvette grand sport.
It's a pretty cool looking convertible.
And I was looking at it online and uh,
one of the benefits was this onstar thing and so they showed it or this guy
fucking calls Onstar is friends driving his car and he says the vehicle stolen
our,
I'll start,
shuts the car down while,
while you're driving.
Yeah.
It,
this research that the universities of California and Washington will present a
paper at a security conference in Oakland,
California next week outlining how they were able to hack into a vehicle's
computer system.
Wow.
It only makes sense,
especially the government man.
It like our,
right,
I threw in Mexicans.
I don't know why I thought that.
Dude,
how crazy is that?
You're running from the cops.
Even your fucking corvette.
You're looking at God damn 1970s movie
and all of a sudden onstar kills your vet.
Yeah.
What kind of gay on American Shit is that?
You know,
I'm not saying you should be allowed to have a car chase everywhere,
but I'm saying maybe sometimes you run from the cops cause you're right.
Okay.
Maybe they're wrong and you're right and you've got to prove them that the one
armed man killed your wife and you know,
and they don't understand you're innocent.
You're just,
you just try to bring those who are responsible to justice.
You know that the cops are gonna let you talk.
They're going to fucking lock you in a,
in a cell when you really need to be out there doing the investigative work to
find out where that killer is.
And you're in the middle of doing this.
Like you're in a goddamn movie.
Fucking cops can't keep up with your vet.
Okay?
You're a fucking faggot.
He asks caprice,
your Shitty old 200,000 mile on caprice with,
with fucking shitty suspension.
It smells like shit when you hit the gas that can't compete with a Goddamn
American corvette.
Not to mention there was a case looks like 2002
that,
uh,
the Scott Peterson case where they got a search warrant to check his vehicles
gps information because he was a for a murder and they got to know where exactly
where he was on that date and stuff like that.
My goodness.
Yeah.
So at,
so it's tracking you and you,
you're sending information to Onstar and if you ever get fucked in like putting
in a weird situation.
I don't even think that's Onstar.
I think that's just his gps,
which is like what we all have.
Oh,
it is audacious onstar.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
So I,
you know,
I always thought for some scary shit.
I don't like that.
Yeah,
but that's what [inaudible] are in your fucking wife either asshole.
Yeah.
That is with every cell phone ping where your phone is.
Some I've heard that it can ping on your phone is with some phones.
Even if your phone isn't on,
like they can ping it.
I heard that too.
How's that possible?
I don't know.
Is there some sort of perpetual power source inside of your phone?
Like a little tiny one?
I think what they're saying is if it,
if,
I mean if there's a battery in it,
you know what I mean?
But it's not on,
if it's not on,
it's shit's never all the way off.
I don't think.
You know what I mean?
Like,
yeah,
like when you turn off like a computer,
there's still power in the computer.
Right?
Yeah,
I've heard that before,
but I don't understand it and know how the fuck is that happening now with your
phone though,
because the phones are pretty much like computers,
you know,
I mean to know that that's true.
That's something nonsense.
No,
I mean if you think about it,
there's,
there's of course there's shit's always going to be on,
you know,
you always hear weird creepy dudes that put like gps on their wife's car fall
around,
but they sell six cars best buy the other day and they had in the clearance
rack,
they had this thing that was for kids that uh,
anytime you want to,
if you know,
you put this thing on your kids,
you know,
kid in anytime you want,
you can go on this computer website and find out exactly where they're at and
track them life.
And it was like 69 bucks or something like that.
I'm thinking like you could easily just buy one of these things and throw it in
somebody's back of their car.
It's,
yeah,
easily.
It's so great.
Yeah,
just glue it to the back of their car somewhere.
Stick it under their bumper or something.
Yeah,
for sure.
They would never find it totally.
How the fuck would,
you know,
dude,
that's a scary ass thing when you think about it.
How many stalkers,
especially if you're a chick,
how many fucking creepy dudes out there that could be,
that's how popper razzies get their shit.
I bet you know.
But they have,
I bet you if you're a high end celebrity that I bet you get tracked all the
time.
Step Holloway Story.
The girl who was,
she was on vacation,
some dudes murder and I remember that they couldn't figure out who killed her.
Right?
So there's a bunch of people that question one of the kids that they had a
question.
He's on the run right now in Chile.
He's running because he killed a woman in Peru,
right?
He killed some chick a in our or hotel room.
Like I guess this dude just likes killing checks.
Okay.
Yeah.
Dexter,
how scary
is that,
man?
This guy's out there running free.
If you have kids,
man,
if you have girls,
especially that stuff really trips you out.
It really trips you out when you start having little people that you care about
or eat,
you know,
wife that you care about or your sister that you care about.
You really start thinking about how fucked up the idea that someone out there
would,
would harm someone weaker than them like that.
Someone would do that and pray off that and that.
That would be the thing all the fucking time,
man.
Especially I just finished watching season two of text or now I'm like really
paranoid about everything.
Well,
there's real people like that out there.
I know.
Like we were talking about the MMA guy that cut his fucking friends heart out.
Yeah.
That's ridiculous.
Some,
some dude in northern California drank some mushrooms with his friend.
He's putting to two things in a terrible light.
MMA and mushrooms.
Drank some mushrooms with his friend and then decided that there was some sort
of a war going on between good and evil and that he had a fucking kill Satan by
cutting his friend's heart out and cooking it.
What the fuck,
son?
Yeah,
and I have never thought to ever do that with mushrooms.
I guess I've never had that kind of mushroom trip where I've gotten violent.
Mine's more like an everything's beautiful life.
Not well,
that's the worry with everything,
man.
It's what are you coming to the table with?
The worry with everything is not,
you know,
what mushrooms do you install?
How fucked up are you before you get the mushrooms in you,
you know,
was it mushrooms that fucked you up or are you just fucking crazy and it was
going to happen anyway?
You know?
I mean if you take a dude who's completely loony and you give a mushrooms,
that's not a good call.
Yeah.
Did you ask,
speaking of know the reason why,
sorry.
You know the reason why that that even exists,
why it happens like that?
It's because mushrooms are illegal.
If mushrooms are illegal,
we would find out what the dosages we would find out like,
oh,
this contains,
you know,
x milligrams of Siliciden,
don't take more than two.
Do not drive.
You know,
it would say some shit on the label,
you know,
and you could say,
Oh hey doctor,
I'm on the antidepressants and,
and I'm on bipolar medication.
Some add shit.
Should I be taking mushrooms and doctor go,
oh no,
no,
no.
If you're going to take mushrooms,
you've got to get off all that other stuff because that'll fuck with the way
your brain chemistry,
you'll totally,
totally misinterpret the world is this guy was probably on some antidepressants
or some shit too.
You know,
I knew some people that are on antidepressants when they would drink,
they would drink and they would get this dude.
I know he gets crazy,
like he's not even there anymore.
It's like he gets like glossy eyed and a,
and he starts saying stupid shit in front of his wife.
He'll say stupid shit and like,
he's like,
like trying to be funny,
but it's not like he's nuts normally.
He's a great guy,
but he has a couple of drinks in him and this fucking loon comes out.
This Weirdo loony guy who doesn't know what he's doing.
He can't control himself.
God bless alcohol.
Crazy,
right?
Yeah.
It's fucking amazing.
Then in 2010 that's the easiest shit to get ahold of.
You know,
but you can't change it.
How are you going to change it?
You're going to deny people there were alcohol after they already have it.
How the fuck you got to do that?
He'd have to get the mushrooms legal.
We spend on drugs and illegal.
We should talk about going to the weed doctor the other day cause we had it as
an interesting thing came up when we were there,
we were talking to our doctor about legalizing marijuana.
It was for or against it and he,
you could see in his eyes he was not,
he was kind of like taken by the question like,
ah,
do I tell him the truth or not?
He's like,
I'm,
he's like,
I'm kind of on the fence.
Tricky
position.
Yeah.
You're a guy who makes a living by giving people a prescriptions and he's not
cheap.
No,
no.
He's a,
he's got an office in Hollywood.
It's probably very expensive to maintain and he just charges some money.
Yeah.
And a,
I give the guy slack because I know that he,
uh,
went to jail.
He was one of the earliest guys who was involved with the medical marijuana
community and a,
he's a real nice guy.
So I like him.
I respect his sacrifice.
So,
you know,
we don't go doctor shopping for someone who's cheaper to get a recommendation.
I just go to him.
But it's weird though,
if you think about it like you,
you want to think these medical marijuana guys that are trying to get,
you know,
Lee,
we'd legalized and stuff.
You want to think they're in it for the right reasons.
But then when you really come down,
and pretty much what he was saying is he's not really happy about it because
he's going to be losing money.
Well,
he's going to be out of a business.
You're going to be out of business,
not just losing money is going to be losing all of his,
yeah.
Right.
So he's not really in it.
So,
you know,
it's weird
afflicted.
He was honest about that.
Yeah.
He was honest about,
well,
you know,
it puts me in a tricky situation and so I was like,
yeah,
what would you do?
And you know,
he started talking about vitamin therapy in a couple of other things that it
does.
Right.
You know,
so yeah.
I mean,
if you look at it from his point of view,
think about it.
The guy gets locked up in jail so that he can,
uh,
keep serving people.
This natural medicine that helps them with all their ailments and he's a doctor.
Okay.
So he's working with cancer patients and he's working with people with glaucoma
and all sorts of different issues that can be assisted by cannabis.
As long as these people can get ahold of good quality stuff.
And he not only fights for that,
believes in that tries to enforce the letter of the law,
which is or tries to operate within the letter of the law,
which was like in 1996 the law was passed in California for medical marijuana
and they want to blocking them in jail.
So you know,
and to have like that kind of sacrifice for something you believe in and
ultimately have it like pulled out from under you with progress.
Well he needs to diversify as fucking business.
He needs to move on to something else with weed.
You know,
you need to start cooking it,
dude.
You know,
that's what you need to do.
Okay.
You're a doctor.
How about you know doctor,
let's call them Johnson.
Dr Johnson's pot cookies.
Have your big smiling face on them.
Make some super fucking badass cookies.
I heard stuff from somebody the other day that they heard from their guys that
they're going to stop edibles
in California.
Edibles are spooky.
You know,
they stopped at a bolts in Holland today.
Yeah,
you can't get an edibles in Holland.
The reason why,
we've talked about this on the show before,
but for the folks that don't know,
when you eat marijuana,
it creates a totally different chemical that is
present when you smoke marijuana but not in psychoactive doses.
And what that means is when you eat it,
when you eat pot,
the THC as it goes through your liver is processing.
There's something that's called 11 hydroxy metabolite and this 11 hydroxy is
four times more psychoactive than THC,
four times stronger,
you know,
per weight of the dose,
but a totally different effect.
It's not the same effect.
Like you know how it is when you get high,
if you just smoke some weed,
you know you get,
you get a certain,
there's a certain sensation,
there's a certain way you see things,
there's a certain door that gets opened,
a certain frequency that gets turned on.
Well,
when you eat it,
it's not the same frequency.
Right.
Don't you feel it?
I mean,
it's fun,
but it's a totally different thing.
It's a totally different drug.
Yeah,
totally.
I don't like actually like edibles at all.
It freaks a lot of people out.
We know people that have had like massive crying fits because they,
they smoked pot and then thought about some shit that they did.
I've done that.
Yeah.
Really?
That always happens on edibles.
Whenever,
whenever I waterfall it,
I always find that,
um,
the,
the edibles make me the most introspective makes me make me the most conscious
about my own personal decisions,
my own personal behavior,
you know,
and it's like they correct me the most,
I get the most corrections from being super high on edibles.
Really.
I feel like I'm tripping,
I think,
and I don't know,
it's just not,
not the right frame of mind at all.
It's so overwhelming and it's so powerful that when,
and this is what happens when you get super,
super high.
When it's so overwhelming and so powerful,
anything negative that's in your mind is going to be brought to the surface and
highlighted.
So it's like this drug or this chemical,
whatever it is,
is this unstoppable force that's in your brain and just wants to run free.
It just wants to spin around and create and the your imagination when you're
super high,
especially if on edibles is really shocking.
Like sometimes I write things and I swear I can't take credit for these ideas
and thoughts because they're just,
they're just being pulled out of the ether by this weed.
I mean that's really what it is,
but it has to have a free track to drive around on.
It has to have free range of your thought.
If there's something that's fucking with you in your head,
you know,
like a relationship that you're trying to get out of or you know,
some argument that you had with your parents that's like really fucking
bothering you.
Something that's really eating away at you,
something you did when you regret doing it,
anything like that.
Any speed bumps are going to be highlighted and you're just going to put
spotlights all over this fucking area of your,
your thought process and it's going to make it very uncomfortable.
So in one way that very uncomfortable feeling,
that paranoia,
that shit is good because it makes you come to grips with some things that maybe
you weren't thinking about correctly or some things that maybe you weren't
giving them your full attention and maybe you had a distorted perception of what
they really are and you know,
the,
the high is going to illuminate it for you.
You know?
So to me it's like,
it's almost like,
like someone yelling at you to clean your room,
you know,
hey,
clean your mind shithead.
He got this stuff that's bugging you,
clean your mind.
But it's not easy.
It's like some high level black belts,
shit,
that's what edibles are.
Edibles are like,
that's like some Shaolin Monk Fucking,
you know,
top of the Temple Dodge and arrows.
Shit.
You know,
you can't just go right into a pot cookie when you know you're not really,
you're,
you,
you're not the type of person that's been exploring their consciousness.
You're not taking yoga,
you're not trying to clean yourself out.
You're just a regular dude with a bunch of fucking problems.
And you know,
some creepy memories in your past and you need a puck cookie,
you could wind up crying yourself to death.
I don't know,
man.
I,
I don't get that feeling from pockets at all.
Did you can get a strong way.
Oh fuck you.
Every now and then you get one.
Yet
to me it's not like I'm learning anything about anything.
It's more of like,
man,
I'm fucked up
and my heart is,
but you don't,
you don't have like an introspective thing where it makes you start thinking
about you yourself and then how you,
how you stand in the world at all.
Wow.
That's weird.
Maybe with me,
it's just triggering some natural responses that already have,
that are always going on anyway.
It's probably what it is.
Yeah.
Um,
so yeah,
the people are saying that the pot edible things in Hollins bullshit that,
that,
that they still saw him there.
You know what?
I think they're right.
I think I'm thinking of mushrooms now that I think about it.
I think the argument was the,
the um,
the edible things was America.
No,
you know what?
I think somebody told me that.
But you know what,
I didn't do any Google search on the Internet,
but I have heard about the edibles thing and California that there's some
concern and you know it's because it's some really potent shit.
What there's not concerned about those.
This Scott,
and I hate to say this cause I don't want to make it illegal.
Salvia is available and fucking head shops.
Yeah,
he can go get Salvia.
And for those folks who don't know,
there's some shit that you can buy in head shops like yeah,
we get like a high times magazine and there's that page when you open it up and
it's like near bud fake bud,
you know?
No,
it's not real.
It doesn't do anything.
It's disgusting.
Yeah.
I talked to one of the dudes from high times and he was telling me that they
make a ton of money off that stuff and I was like,
that makes me sad.
I think I remember as a kid buying shit that was fake just just in case if it
works,
you know like I remember doing,
I don't know if it was fake weed or why,
but it was like,
I remember it was a lot of money.
It was like 30 40 bucks and I feel like one of those things that we were 18 we
were like,
oh yeah,
I could feel it.
I can feel it.
Yeah,
yeah,
no and I was when I was like 12 we used to smoke everything.
We just smoked bamboo leaves bananas.
You smoked banana?
Yeah.
Have you ever done that banana?
Because yeah,
you can smoke banana peels.
It's bananas.
We tried smoking,
all sorts of stuff.
We've got cigars.
I tried chewing tobacco.
Kids are stupid.
They try all sorts of stupid shit.
But snuff,
snuff is that stuff.
It's like ground up tobacco and it's like got all sorts of shit and mental and
it's probably like this filled with chemicals and you stuff it in between your
cheek and your gum and it gives you this mad nicotine rush.
How great is it that Lindsay Lohan found a loophole to get her drugs during this
probation time?
Did you hear about this?
No,
I didn't hear about this.
You were just talking about though,
cause I had a point snuff.
But before that,
uh,
you can go to head shops and get anything else Salvia,
but people are trying to make,
um,
at a bull's illegal dude.
Salvia is like a major psychedelic drug.
And for people who don't know,
it's an a really intense experience.
You've done it a bunch of times,
right?
How many times do you done like seven,
six?
That's some out of body Shit,
right?
Yeah,
it's like mushrooms.
But the thing about Salvia is,
is that it takes you to,
it opens up your brain into like a rural,
if you're,
especially if you're used to psychedelics,
you,
it's,
it's a familiar world.
Like it's,
it's a,
it's crazy.
It's like doing a whippet of mushrooms.
But,
uh,
I had to stop doing it because I was doing it maybe once every couple of weeks,
but I started thinking like,
all right,
this is not,
this is not good.
This is opening up something that's probably never going to be able to be
completely shut.
And that's what a lot people that d DMT,
I,
I don't think it's a good idea.
Uh,
I think there's certain things of the brain that once it's opened,
you're going to be thinking about that shit forever.
Kind of like,
do you know what I mean?
That's one of the reasons why I haven't done DMT in years.
I haven't done DMT in three years at least.
And that's when the,
one of the reasons why it's because the last time I did it,
it made,
it was like an,
an undeniable alteration of my view of reality that I had to become comfortable
with.
Right.
It's like you have a certain reality that you live in,
you know,
and then you smoke a little pot and that reality shifts and like,
Whoa,
now I'm in the pot reality.
You know?
It's like I'm still in the same place.
I'm still drunk,
but I'm in a different frequency.
I'm like tuning into a different frequency.
That's how I always describe any sort of psychedelic experience,
whether it's mild,
like you know,
pot or intense like DMT,
but the DMT one,
when I came back to sobriety,
you know,
when the pot one comes back to sober,
then I'm always the same.
You know,
I'm driving down the same street.
I see the same people,
I wave.
It all feels the same to me.
Whereas when I'm high and I,
I,
you know,
run into somebody or I'm out doing my thing,
it feels weird.
It feels weird.
But then when I sober up,
it's all normal again.
Well,
with the DMT thing,
once I sobered up,
it wasn't normal again.
It didn't get normal.
It didn't get normal for weeks.
Yeah.
When I came back,
I was the same person.
I was living in the same house.
I had the same life,
but I had seen something that there was no way I was ever gonna Forget.
And my whole view of reality completely shifted.
So I had to think,
now I just have to get comfortable with this new view.
So it took like two weeks before my new view of reality before I felt like a
normal person during normal days,
but for two whole weeks,
man,
I remember I,
the way I describe it as that reality felt very slippery.
So you don't think that happens at least in a micro kind of way with a smoking
weed or eating wheat?
Um,
I think is if you don't give recovery period,
I think it certainly alters the way you look at the world and perhaps
permanently,
you know,
I think,
potheads in general have a,
a completely different way of looking at things then people don't smoke pot.
I don't think that's a coincidence.
And I think one of the reasons that's one of the reasons why pots here in the
first place.
I think the reason why we have these reactions to these plants and these plants
give us these,
uh,
these reactions and give us this different way of looking at things and seeing
things.
I think that's what they're there for.
I think there's a symbiotic relationship that we have between us and those
plants.
And those plants are there to assist in our evolution.
I think they're there to assist in our changing of our thinking.
And I think that's what they do.
They shape our thinking,
they round things out,
they take away a lot of the sharp,
jagged,
retarded edges of normal thinking,
you know,
and I think the introspective minus,
uh,
that they bring is one of the big parts about it.
The,
the ability to step back and objectively kind of assess your life and look at it
and the squashing of your ego.
I mean the,
the intimidation and the,
uh,
the feeling of paranoia that you get when you smoke pot.
Part of that is,
you know,
the,
the ego,
uh,
gets exposed and you don't,
you,
your defense mechanisms drop and you a,
you'd lighten it all up.
You start to look at things for what they really are,
you know,
I mean,
that's,
that's why I think it's there.
I don't think it's for everybody,
you know,
I don't think,
uh,
I don't think it should be done.
If you don't know what you're doing.
I think the problem with everything being illegal is that we don't have any
shama anymore.
You know,
it's a,
it's a goofy name for it,
but maybe there could be sort of a psychedelic consultant that you go to,
you know,
and the psychedelic consultant is a professional,
a guy who's professionally adept at navigating psychedelic world.
So maybe that's what our pot doctor should turn into.
Yeah,
that's what he should turn into.
But that Shit's illegal too.
You know,
you can't just potheads aren't gonna pay.
So you could tell them how to get high with it.
You know,
pot busts too easy,
but like mushrooms,
but whatever,
you're getting massaged by an Asian chick.
Why he's doing it.
Oh,
so you should have like a combo business now you thinking,
see if you were that doctor,
you wouldn't have to worry about the future.
You'd be all pro pot because you've got some backup plans.
Right.
That's pretty dope move,
Dude.
Uh,
you smoke some weed and get a massage by a really hot Asian check and they read,
read like inspirational quotes to you.
Yeah.
Why not?
Man.
Why can't that be a real business?
Think of it.
That's how it has actually sounds pretty promising,
man.
You'd start a chain of those.
Hmm.
Well,
what would you call them?
Uh,
hello
titty.
Pretty girl.
Rub.
Rub To enlightenment.
Too many words.
Too many words,
right?
Uh,
is this real pretty girl massage too in la?
Maybe.
Is this real life?
Who would call it that?
That's it.
Like the kid that dentists,
yeah,
they came back from the dentist.
This real life.
It's real life.
Hey Dude,
I went to,
it's rural life.
They have this new girl.
You got it.
Got It.
Smoke the train wreck and have her talk about it.
This is how funny.
Dana White's,
um,
his uh,
birthday party for his 40th birthday was this awesome bash that they threw.
Fram total surprise.
It was in Vegas at a,
of the big hotels.
This whole fucking conference room and everything.
They had it all set up.
He had no idea.
He goes down there and he walks in the door.
Everybody's waiting.
Surprise.
So this is how craziest party was.
Fucking stone temple pilots played.
Oh Wow.
The stone temple pilots got up and they weren't the,
that Guy Scott Wieland is that his name is the one who's always on heroin.
Yeah,
he's,
he's talented as fuck.
Dude.
That guy was inspirationally talented but crazy as all fuck.
Like it was taking a while to get the party started to get everybody see and
everything like that.
And they wanted more money.
They're threatening,
they wanted to fucking leave.
They were going to quit.
Like,
yeah,
there was all sorts of,
I mean,
I'm getting this all third hand so it could be total bullshit,
but you know,
I didn't actually talk to him,
but uh,
we did like bring them up,
you know,
I introduced them.
I,
you know,
said happy birthday to Dana.
And then I said,
Ladies Gentlemen,
without further ado,
stone temple pilots,
everybody went fucking crazy.
Like he couldn't believe the actual stone temple pilots were there.
So anyway,
they play this intense concert.
I mean,
that mother fucker is so good.
He's so tight and so professional and nails,
every fucking single movement.
He just,
it was really one of the best live performances I've ever seen.
Was it all the same old songs.
That's why.
Yeah.
That's why it was so tight.
It doesn't matter.
I don't give a fuck.
That's true.
But God damn it was good.
I understand that.
But I love those songs.
So God damn.
Anyway,
and it's over.
Uh,
Dana goes on stairs stage takes,
the microphone goes.
That just happened.
That's cool.
Like that just happened and you know,
they want to get out of there.
They want to get their check and [inaudible] just stand there looking at all his
friends,
talking to them like that just happened,
you know.
I mean it was like one of those moments where you're like,
wow,
that motherfucker just had stone temple pilots play his birthday party.
That's awesome.
Could you imagine coming out to your backyard and you know,
who would be your band ween?
Would it be weaned?
You know,
Wean?
Probably Navy.
Yeah.
If you had like Mc Chris show up at your house and he's playing in your
backyard,
he'd be,
you know,
it's surprised you is Mc Chris,
your stone temple pilots?
No,
no,
no.
I know,
I know.
Mc Christ.
That's a problem.
Cool.
That's gay.
They do can be.
Who would be your,
uh,
your stone temple pilots?
Nine snails back in the day.
Maybe.
I don't know.
For me,
sound
garden when they were at their peak,
blow up the outside world,
those songs,
man,
that was when I first started smoking weed when I first started getting into
sound garden.
And I remember I was at the comedy store ones and uh,
you know,
we're hanging out all night,
having a good time.
And I was leaving and in my car on the way home,
I listened to spoon man and it was so fucking good.
I played it all the way home.
I just kept repeating it.
Every time we'd go to the next song I go right back to it.
I listened to spoon,
man,
I don't know how many times it takes me 20 minutes drive home.
I was this spoon man,
at least five times.
Wow.
Cause it's just so good.
You know,
you don't even know what music sounds like until you start smoking pot.
You don't even know what you're missing.
There's,
there's certain sounds that you're not going to feel.
There's certain the F or at least I'm not going to,
I don't know how music affects you,
but for me,
when I smoked pot,
it makes me way more connected to music.
Eddie says the same shit.
Like,
like when he listens to music and when he does music,
well,
we just intensifies everything.
Obviously if you will see a movie on weed,
it's going to be more intense and awesome than it is without,
you know,
everything.
Sex Too.
People don't realize that.
And emotions.
Emotions.
Yeah.
Waterfalls.
Tell stall.
Tell us all waterfalls.
You know what I was just thinking who would be my personal view?
Benfold
den folds five.
Yeah.
Ben Folds.
What about John Mayer?
Don't you think he'd be jealous?
What?
John Marriage just had to cancel his European tour.
Oh,
him and Carlos.
No,
don't be mean to kick him,
man.
Wise down that.
Um,
yeah.
So for like modern bands,
man,
shit,
I don't know.
I think house of pain would be fucking Badass.
Yeah.
I miss that.
Dana had a concert in Boston for Saint Patrick's day and yet house of Payne play
Everlast is the coolest.
I love that.
Dude,
my drug dealer was in Ohio,
was so addicted to house of Payne.
Come over and be like,
what's up Brandon?
He turns on jump around or whatever that
I like when Marcus Davis fights,
but one of the main reasons why it's just,
I love Marcus Davis,
but also so I could hear that fucking song.
That's one of the best walkout songs ever.
Yeah.
That fucking song is the shit,
man.
They just smashed that one,
you know?
And then they had a hard time coming up with anything that could top that.
That song was just such an out of the ballpark smash hit.
You know?
It wasn't until Everlast got on his own like that.
What?
It's like song,
but that's another,
that's a fucking classic.
That's an all time classic.
Wait,
every class I'm thinking of taking a swim past the breakers and left my,
the world die.
No,
that,
oh my God,
you faggot.
That's slightly different band.
Our clear is jump around,
jump up,
jump up again.
Down jump.
I'm the king of that.
No,
no,
no.
I thought you were talking about some else,
their mind.
I thought you were talking about Everlast the band.
No,
never last.
The lead singer,
right?
You faggot.
I know you were thinking of,
is that the other band called Everlast?
Oh No,
never cleared.
Ever clear.
Total polar homosexual opposite of house and paid.
I know.
I was just like,
but by the way,
I'm a bad ass band still.
I love that song.
You do these on access Hollywood now it's an e or something like that.
No,
that's my just fucking Tyler.
Everybody together.
Ben Hur.
Chief Simmons just died.
Oh No,
it was Ronnie James Dio.
You're just,
you just fucking connecting people,
man.
You know that was the weirdest
ever any show that I ever did.
The New Year's show when when Gene Simmons showed up for the new year's show,
like to watch my new year's show,
I freaked out.
I've never freaked out at people coming to see my show before,
but I legitimately freaked out.
I was like nervous.
You know,
I've had famous people come to see the show and talk to me before they see it
and you know,
and like,
you know,
it doesn't,
it doesn't freak me out.
Like once I got a little nervous when Penn was in the audience because I was
hanging out with pen from Penn and teller.
He's cause I respect him and he's a cool guy.
So I got a little weirded out and I was like,
Oh shut it off.
Can't bomb bomb.
I got to my rights.
And that's the worst state of mind to get into for comedy.
But when,
when Gene Simmons was in the audience and the New Year's show,
I was like,
Holy Shit,
that's fucking Gene Simmons.
Like to me,
when I was a little kid,
you know,
when I was a kiss fan,
when I was like fucking 12 and shit,
I had kissed posters on my wall and you know,
I get in arguments with kids at school because they would say kisses for fags.
So I had to hide my kiss collection.
I had to hide my love for kiss when dudes would come over my house.
Like the first time if I didn't know them,
I hid my kiss stuff just like makeup Joe.
I too,
I don't do it like a little like Megan attrical like high heels and I looked at
makeup.
I just loved the whole thing where they had,
you know,
they had like the whole pageantry of the fucking show.
You know,
they had the demon,
the Star Child,
the fucking lover,
the whole thing.
Man,
I was a fucking huge kiss fan.
I still am.
I still love some of their jams.
I like fucking throwing them on driving.
Yeah.
I was made for loving you.
There's a good video of you doing a Karaoke version of love guns.
If Google search kiss carry over
Joe Rogan.
That was fun,
man.
That was fun as shit.
That was a,
that was a fun radio show that show a Sarah and no name.
Yeah,
but they're not together anymore.
no names.
Got his own Gig and she's got her own gig.
Radio is a grind man.
It's hard.
You know,
the Missus Rogan had to get something fixed on her car,
so she got a rental car and she was telling me,
she was like,
when you don't listen to satellite radio for awhile,
you realize how much regular radio stuff.
You know what those satellite radio is starting to suck now too.
Because I mean the,
they're now getting censored by the,
uh,
you know,
like I think opie and Anthony were talking about it the other day where they are
in an allowed to puke anymore or do sounds of puking or anything leaving the
body.
Like they can't talk about shitty.
That's like that.
Their baby bird bit,
they did it back in the day.
They went and been able to do that anymore.
Well,
they just aired it though,
did they?
Other day I was driving home and I was listening to Opie and Anthony and I
wasn't really paying attention,
but I heard screams and cheers and I was like,
what could fucking possibly be eliciting this kind of reaction?
And then I said,
oh my God,
this is the baby bird.
And I turned it off.
So I had just gotten in the car,
you know,
and I turned it up and you hear it like everything.
I heard bill burrs voice and then I heard my own voice and I was like,
oh wow.
But yeah that's weird though cause like it's satellite radio is now turning into
regular radio in some ways and also a lot of these music channels that almost
seems like they,
like I was talking about this last night with some dude how he was saying like
how satellite radio to him sounds like they just like they're playing like
looped cds.
Like they have a CD,
like a mixed tape and they're just looping the same,
you know like he's like I don't need to hear music channels.
Yeah.
Like I don't need to hear Bush five times a day.
You for real.
They should have real DJ's take the opportunity to go back to real DJ's.
One Guy,
no we haven't talked about this now we're one guy is like some fucking Ku Wolf
Man Jack type character.
He talks some shit in between the songs and he plays what he likes.
That's the future is just rhapsody and,
and,
and are not rhapsody a fuck about Pandora and like all those like blips and
stuff like that because that's what the future is.
Like if you like what you,
I don't know if you ever used Pandora,
if you like Pandora a,
if you like,
say like Ben Folds,
you type in Ben folds or wean.
And then what it does is it makes a radio station based on what other users who
liked that band.
Like also.
And so what happens is like they'll play ween,
then they'll play another band that's like other people that like wing like and
either say yes or no.
You voted up and down and it just kind of starts building the perfect radio
station.
Yeah,
that's brilliant.
That's brilliant.
And what that's missing now is the camaraderie of a Dj.
I remember when I used to do construction and um,
I used to listen to Charles Laquidara in the morning,
uh,
the,
the morning blanket or the morning mattress.
He,
uh,
the big mattress,
that's what it was called.
It was this cool comedy radio show that was on,
uh,
in Boston.
And like,
you know,
this is like the early eighties,
like 1981 or some shit like that.
And uh,
you,
you felt like you had a connection with this dude.
You know,
like you would hear him like talk and then he would play a song or you know,
all the other Djs to mark Parenteau is in the afternoon.
He would talk and they would play a song.
Like that guy became a part of your afternoon,
you know,
it's like he would play the shit that he wanted to play.
Like I remember I was listening to this one station knows WC cozy that'd be coc
back in Boston was called kick ass rock and roll.
And the Dj said,
you know what,
I'm going to play a guy something just because it's good and it's not even rock.
It's a Michael Jackson Song.
I'm gonna play this just because it's good.
And he played Billy Jean and I remember like,
like at this crazy motherfucker,
he decided to not even play a rock song.
He's like playing a Michael Jackson Song.
But it was so fucking good.
Nobody gave a shit.
You know,
but it was like those chances you can't take today,
you,
you got to still not allowed demand that.
Yeah.
Cause it's all based on money like advertising and all that stuff.
In order for them to be able to have jobs so they are not allowed to play
certain songs because the music industry or record labels won't let them play
those songs,
you know,
etc.
That's what sucks man.
The old days of a real DJ,
I think if satellite radio was smart,
they would concentrate on hiring like really interesting personality.
It's just be djs.
Just some do that you get used to listening to some dude who says some
interesting shit in between the songs.
You know,
some guy has got an interesting point of view,
gives you some,
some trivia about the band or something.
Then will you liked the guy and you're like his taste in music.
You know who it should be.
Is that guy from opn?
Anthony?
I'm the guy who did a guest host once a member and we listened to it last time
we were on the show.
Uh,
Rich Vos.
No,
no,
no.
The guy that works for them that,
that's like their bodyguard or Steve,
the manager member.
He did a guest,
uh,
hour on radio where he deejayed and we all listened to it last time we were
there,
the big tall guy,
Kenny Kenny.
Oh,
exactly.
Club Soda Cap.
So to Kinda know where going with this,
I don't know why I have clubs on a and just in the back of my head at all times.
Um,
he did that disco thing.
He was,
uh,
he was as a Dj on that,
the disco channel.
Any,
I don't think have they ever aired this,
but he was just swearing and saying all kinds of crude shit and was really
hilarious and playing like a character,
like a DJ character.
And it was awesome.
It made you look forward to the end of the song so you could hear them talk some
more shit.
It was like fun,
you know?
Yeah.
The problem is for every person who loves club Soda,
Kenny,
there's going to be another person probably somewhere who hates.
That's the good thing about satellite radio.
It's like cable.
They can have a million radio stations,
but then,
but they're not willing to do that.
It's the same reason why they're telling them not to make poopy sounds.
So like they're worried about any negative.
They're not worried about the positive.
No one's going to pay extra for poopy sounds,
but there's going to be some people that they hear them talk about shit and
diarrhea and they just tune out and just like,
that's it.
I don't even want,
and they're worried about advertisers,
you know,
like not wanting to be associated with poopy talk.
You know that they're going to lose something.
So that's why,
you know,
like a,
a guy who's like a real crazy Dj,
like a club Soda Kenny,
that Shit,
it's not going to fly because he's going to offend too many people.
We live in a pussy ass world.
I think the Internet,
is this going to be the radio?
Like this shit right here,
like podcasts.
But the problem is that now they're going to fuck with this.
You know,
how's it going to fuck with this?
They're finished.
They're going to find a way to edit it or sensory,
you know,
they're going to,
well,
eventually you'll be able to do this from your own computer.
You don't have to worry about that.
Eventually,
you're gonna be able to do something like Ustream.
You won't need to use to them.
Not that we don't love Ustream,
they're all very cool with us and everything,
but you're gonna be able to do this kind of shit from your home computer.
You're gonna be able to do this shit on your home network.
What do you mean?
You're going to be able to like have your own Ustream set up on your own
computer?
You're not going to have to have some crazy server and the server handles all
this video.
There's going to become some,
some new innovations can allow people to do this kind of shit right from their
own complete.
Didn't already do that.
Yeah.
But not with these kinds of numbers.
Like how many people are tuned into this thing,
right?
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
So you're all sort of 1300 year old here and that's kind of a bandwidth thing.
So,
yeah.
So yeah,
you'd be able to serve it eventually.
That won't be an issue.
Just like 14 four baud modems could never even download pictures took forever.
You know,
you'd never be able to do this on the old school
[inaudible] name.
I remember the first time I clicked on an ISD in line,
I didn't make that noise.
I was like,
this is incredible.
He just get online.
There's no noise.
How do you know when it's on cut out?
That's a ringtone.
I want just that sound of dialing up.
I bet you can get it.
Oh,
I bet that's it.
If not somebody make it.
That is a credit to ring tone.
Yeah.
Throw that shit up on Twitter.
Homeys makeup ring tone.
Yeah,
please do.
that sound man,
that,
that getting on the phone and dialing up modem sound.
Somebody make a ringtone for iPhone,
please.
There was a time when that was the way to get online and you couldn't get online
if you had your phone on.
If you were like,
if someone couldn't use the phone while you were online,
my mom still has that Internet,
you know?
It's a,
uh,
I don't know if you've ever had AOL and back in the,
they used
to when private messaging first came out,
like instant message.
Every time you get an instant message it would say this voice,
the same guy that did you got Moodle would say instant message and then you get
like a window that pops up and goes hi,
how are you doing?
Then you'd write back and then they write back and goes instant message.
And I remember that that was really cool.
It was like wow there's this voice telling me they have a message.
But then it got so popular that like for a good couple months AOL was must have
been freaking out because that cause it would just go in an instant,
instant,
instant message cause everyone was a messaging back and forth cause it just like
it became Twitter overnight.
So everyone was instant messaging.
So it was just the most annoying shit ever.
Like you're just walking to your house and you just,
your instant,
instant,
instant miss.
Oh
I remember when you got mail was cool.
You got mail,
you've gotten mail,
you've got mail.
Remember when that was cool.
Yeah.
You should have that for your text messages.
You've got mail every time a text comes in that that should be your sound.
Okay.
The guy that did that voice,
I think was this is the same that you used to do some Disney advertisements or
something like this was coming soon.
Get Tuesday.
That shouldn't be available.
That you've got mail should be available as a ringtone.
Yeah.
Shouldn't it be okay if I can take,
I'm sure it is somewhere.
It better be.
I'll be very disappointed that I used to love that sound me too.
Until I had it for like a couple months and then after awhile you're like,
what the shot is that,
was there an option to shut that noise out?
I remember,
but I remember on the instant messaging,
I don't think there was,
that's why it was so annoying cause like AOL had to update it so they,
they turn,
they got rid of it.
Yeah.
You know,
so I remember um,
w what was the other,
there was another type of,
uh,
chat like that,
Iq.
Yeah,
ICQ.
Exactly.
I still have my ICQ number.
You really,
it's like 512 or something.
That's crazy.
Do people still use that shit?
Uh,
I don't know.
Yeah,
they do.
Yeah.
I see accused like only the elite and Meredy.
The Super League nerds.
Yeah.
That was back of my quick plane days.
Everybody in quake had ICQ I knew would get online and quick clan,
like my Icq name was my quake name,
crime eight XD and I'd get online and all the other quick clan members would go
on and we had messaged each other about what server you are going to be on and
there was a,
a way that you could click on the link.
They would send you a link to the server,
you click on it from ICQ and it would fire up your quake game and take your
right to that server to,
those were the days,
man.
Those are the days I,
all I wanted to do was get home and fucking play quick.
That's the baby screaming in the hallway.
That's what happens when you live with kids.
They start screaming and shit.
Yeah.
God Damn.
Little Banshee.
Woo.
We have seven more minutes and then we're going to call it this time we're going
to do it at two,
two hours.
Yeah.
I feel like we started petering out about 10 minutes ago.
Yeah,
I agree.
Not really fired it back then,
a long podcast,
but it's pretty amazing.
But it's,
it's,
you know what I think is the way to do it.
Cause then you get deep into conversations.
Yeah.
You know,
and in an hour sometimes we just touch on things right when we touch on them.
Yeah.
You know,
at the end,
uh,
you know,
we've run out of time.
Um,
what else did I want to talk to you about?
Oh,
the fucking oil spell thing,
man.
The latest thing on the oil spill was that they're not going to be able to stop
it until they dig into these extra wells to make these relief wells,
they're going to have to relief wells.
They wanted to make one,
but the government forced them to drill to relief wells because the area they're
trying to hit to intersect these two wells is like seven and a half inches.
And they have to go like a fucking mile underwater and underground to hit this
well a mile and it's going to take them until August.
And even that is not guaranteed,
but until then it's just going to keep poor and oil.
And there was a thing on Rachel Maddow where they showed the same company that
built this,
this well also built a well that in 1979 did the same fucking thing in 1979 in
the Gulf of Mexico.
It's spilled out for sure.
Nine months.
Wow.
Really?
For nine months until they figured out how to stop it.
Nine fucking months.
I think it's gonna be crazy.
Like I know everyone made fun of the CNN for doing this,
but I just think it's gonna be crazy hurricane season during all mixing in with
all this,
you know,
dude,
it's terrifying.
What if it just becomes like fire tornadoes and it's,
it really,
it really could be.
I mean,
people don't know how dangerous that is.
If you get hurricanes and they start taking that oil,
which is literally the size of Maryland.
Now there's an oil slick that's a size of a state and it takes that shit and
flies it through the fucking air and it's going to whip it up and like tornadoes
and shit and fly it through the fucking air.
I mean,
it's literally going to take that,
that oil and throw it all over everything.
People's houses and cars and trees and,
and if something happens and a fire starts,
dude,
that is like some biblical Shit.
Yeah.
That's about 2012.
That's some biblical Shit.
A state on fire.
Wow.
Fire tornadoes.
Yeah.
That's so cool.
Dude.
How's anybody that sucks.
That sucks.
It does suck the fire.
I want to see a fire tornado though.
I want to see it in a lab.
May contain a movie into the road movie.
Did I watch some one,
um,
one documentary where they showed this very specific geographic feature of the
earth when they were having a hard time figuring out how it was created and they
uh,
they chalked it off to some insane like instantaneous superstorm that like
literally destroyed like half of this mountain side and,
and read cut through this,
you know,
like tornado is all kinds of crazy shit caught this landscape.
He started looking at shit like that and you,
you start thinking of what the possibilities actually are,
what could happen at any moment.
Some nutty shit could happen any day,
any time,
any minute of any day.
Some of the things that have happened to this earth like over the past make that
sink hole in Guatemala look like nothing.
This is one of them,
man.
Yeah.
This oil spill thing is pretty crazy because there's a lot of God damn oil.
There's a lot of goddamn tankers out there.
There's a lot of God damn oil rigs out there in the ocean.
You know,
if somebody was a real anarchist instead of trying to fuck up the world by
blowing up a building,
they would start blowing those fucking things up.
Yeah.
I think they try a lot.
I bet.
Do you,
I bet they do.
They should have warships that are around those things at all times,
you know,
but then they'd probably fuck up and blow it up accidentally.
Some suicidal,
crazy sailor type dude.
Yeah.
Accidentally suck this first deck.
Can't take it.
It's problem.
Sure.
There's some fail safes to keep them from doing that.
Right.
Yeah,
totally different having access to missiles and she states that this shit there
and happen.
Well,
the crazy thing is that the,
they made this a,
not even to their own safety specifications.
They got a waiver on it because it was taking too long to make,
so the valve that they used or the whatever they use to to cap this oil well
off,
it was not the best shit.
They did not use the,
the,
uh,
the recommended and required shit.
They got some sort of a,
some sort of a break because they were a like way behind and budget and so they,
they spent less money and put this thing up quicker.
And the,
the real hazard with those,
that sometimes gaskets inside of him,
that's what causes explosions and it's exactly what fucking happened.
That's what happened in 1979 same goddamn thing happen.
And still from then to now,
they,
they literally have it come up with any new ways of stopping the oil.
They don't have any backup plans.
They just figured it happens.
So rarely we're just going to suck as much money out as humanly possible.
Fuck everybody else.
And then,
you know,
if something happens we'll deal with it.
But hopefully nothing will happen
I guess to please the UFC fans,
which you think about the restorative rain page recap.
Oh,
or there's are a lot of UFC fans.
Are you asking him about the Rashad?
So interesting fight,
you know,
I think rampage came into that fight too heavy.
Um,
I think he was aware of that.
Yeah,
he was 250 pounds and the weight class is two oh five.
So he had 45 pounds to lose.
Not really,
you know,
35 really is going to cut some weight,
cut about 10 pounds.
Um,
but that's a lot of weight to lose in a training camp.
It's a tremendous amount of weight.
So he had to think about that,
I think more than he should have.
And uh,
Rashad was coming off of,
uh,
the fight with Thiago Silva,
so he's in excellent shape.
And so he came right from one fight,
jumped back and training and gotten training camp for the next fight with,
you know,
a good amount of downtime to recover,
but not too much.
So it was really optimum for him,
for Rashad.
And he made the most of it.
I mean,
if you saw the prime time shows,
they're really good.
Those primetime shows get you fucking fired up,
man.
They're really like in depth on the training and show all the preparations,
everything.
And Rashad was throwing it down,
man,
his training was insane.
He was doing all these crazy sprints and uh,
like with a parachute on,
they put a parachute on his back and he's doing sprints and he's doing all these
things where he's like pushing sleds and all his explosive energy shit.
And uh,
it really showed in the fight.
Man,
he moves so fast when he charged out like right at the opening bell and crack
rampage in the jaw,
I was like really shocked at how fast he moved.
You know,
it was really,
really intense.
And he executed a perfect game plan.
He kept away from the danger,
which is rampage power shots.
And uh,
he implemented his strategy controlling him and taking him down and beating him
up when he's,
you know,
when on the outside and getting away from Rampage's counters.
But he did get clipped once.
That was the most interesting part of the fight besides the opening seconds when
he cracked him.
The most interesting part of the fight was when rampage hit him.
He hurt him bad.
His legs gave out.
It was flat on his ass.
Yeah.
And the third round he got hurt bad,
but he kept his composure.
Got Ahold of rampage and even reverse the position.
So it was,
it was a huge round for him just as far as like being able to overcome the worst
case scenario,
the worst case scenarios.
Rampage clips you,
he hurts you and he's on top of you and you're on the bottom.
That's the worst position you could ever be in with a guy like rampage because
he's so fucking powerful.
He hits so hard and Rashad kept his shit together and kept a hold of them and
got out of the situation.
You know,
I was,
I was impressed,
man.
I thought it was a,
an entertaining fight.
I,
I enjoyed the fuck out of it.
Some people criticized him.
I didn't even see that UFC,
but I heard that everyone,
uh,
was really upset about it.
Really?
Yeah.
Who's everyone?
Every person I talked to who you're talking to a bunch of faggots.
Something about it.
It just,
uh,
it was,
well,
people sometimes assume it was just poking
wall installed them.
That's what they're saying.
A lot of people say that we'll just fucking wall installed,
man.
It totally dude,
wall install.
No,
no.
What he did was he dealt with a very dangerous challenger and a very intelligent
way.
I don't think there's anything wrong with what he did.
I think he did.
What he did is what you have to do.
You can't just go in there and banging out with rampage,
just going to clip you and you're going to go to sleep.
That's just fact.
I was just the way it goes.
You know,
rampage has a distinct advantage with most people.
If most dudes want to stand there and trade with rampage,
rampage is going to fuck them up.
The only guy that I've ever seen go after rampage and Stan,
a trade with them was Vandelay and the first two fights,
and that was when rampage was not that well trained.
He wasn't,
uh,
he wasn't nearly as good a shape as he is now as it wasn't nearly as technical,
didn't have nearly as good at training partners.
It was those fights and in those fights,
you know,
Vandelay fucking chased after him.
That was,
that was pretty exciting shit.
Vandelay a slugged it out with them.
He really went after him and the chocolate,
I'll fight.
That's another one.
Chuck.
Uh,
especially the first one in pride.
They really slugged it out,
but it's hard to come out on top with it.
With,
with Quintin like that.
He's just so powerful,
man.
Dudes get get in brawls with him.
He just blast them.
You've got to fight that guy.
Smart.
You know?
Vandelay got away with it,
but Vandelay was in his prime back then and he caught rampage when grand page
wasn't quite prepared.
He wasn't the same rampage that is now.
You know,
patients has a lot of power.
So I think we were shot.
There was a very smart thing.
I think he fought real good.
It was exciting.
I enjoy the shit out of it.
The big,
the highlight to me though of the whole night was that Mike Russell,
Todd Duffy fight.
Did you see that?
Okay,
we got to,
you got to see that because it's the craziest fucking thing you'll ever see in
your life.
You see a guy who's built like you,
okay,
he's built like he's got a gun.
Okay,
I'm not,
I'm not being mean.
He's built worse than you.
How about that?
You are more sexy than him.
Feel better.
Anyway,
this guy is getting his ass kicked by Todd Duffy character who looks like he was
made in a lab like literally.
If you just just do me a favor and Google.
Google Mike Russ,
so,
okay.
Todd Duffy.
Yeah,
chaos.
You got to put a no,
no,
no.
Duffy is d.
U f.
F.
E.
That's it.
There you go.
I know how Google works.
She,
yeah,
but you clicked on the wrong link.
You just clicked on the wrong line.
She,
you want me to do video?
Yeah,
you got to go with the video.
You got to see this because anyway,
this,
that's it right there.
It's the most ridiculous thing ever because now that's not it.
That's the wrong one.
That's the first.
That's the first fight that Todd Duffy ever had.
No,
those are all Todd Duffy.
Tim Hag.
Anyway,
not important.
Okay.
This guy is getting his ass kicked for for three rounds for two and a half
rounds and he's fat and he's like really out of shape.
It looks like he's got like this belly that hangs over his gut and his Todd
Duffy character looks like fucking Gi Joe.
Man.
He looks ridiculous.
He's got this square iron looking jaw.
His whole body's chiseled out of granite and he'd just teeing off on this Mike
Russell Guy.
It looks like the worst mismatch you've ever seen in a fight.
Like one guy,
old school,
no,
even worse because this God,
they're there because they're both,
they both have modern skills.
Just one of them is so much faster,
so much more athletic.
Okay,
so this Todd Duffy is teeing off on Mike Ross,
just fucking them up where you can't believe the shots Russell's taking.
You're like,
this is just a matter of time.
And after getting his ass kicked for two fucking rounds,
he goes into the third round out of nowhere,
catches Mike Todd Duffy with one punch and flatten them out cold.
So this fat guy is getting his ass kicked for the entire fight and lands one
shot.
And this Adonis who looks like he could get hit in the head by a fucking media
and he'd be fine.
He gets clipped with one shot and goes unconscious arms behind his head and the
whole place goes fucking insane.
People were standing up.
People were pissed because they weren't watching because it was getting boring
because the one guy was just teeing off on the other guy.
Dude,
the craziest Shit I've ever seen in a thousand years of fighting thousand fights
rather a thousand years.
How old am I?
1,000 fights over 10 years.
The craziest Shit I've seen by far was this knockout.
Huh?
Have to find it.
You got to see it.
I think you need to see,
check it out with doctor Steve Berle.
What does that is a new show.
Uh,
based off our,
is the spin off of Tim and Eric Show.
It just started off adult swim.
It's every Sunday night at midnight,
but check it out.
Tivo that it's only 15 minutes long,
but it's so ridiculously awesome.
It's called check it out with doctor.
Steve Rule will love it.
I'm looking out for it.
Uh,
so we should talk about the flash light at the end too.
If you guys,
uh,
could have fleshlight.com or go to Joe's Rogan's website and click on the banner
on the right side.
They are official sponsor of the podcast.
And if you click on their banner,
you get 15% off your order.
And I highly recommend getting some of the flesh light lotion or oil.
It's the best stuff even to use without a flashlight.
Oh,
here,
look at this.
flashlight.com
one punch.
This is the fight.
Did the other guy out of nowhere,
the other guy is a fucking a monster or a destroyer.
The owner of the fastest Kao in UFC history and this fat guy clips on with one.
We'll hit this one punch of bang out of nowhere.
Boom.
That's it.
I'll cold.
It was like you shut off.
It was crazy fights,
dude.
There's nothing more unpredictable than an MMA fight.
You could be watching a soccer game and a team together getting fucked up for
the entire,
you know,
most of the,
most of the game,
a team can't come back and the final four seconds and when you know,
but in an MMA fight,
you're always in danger.
You can always lose it.
A soccer match,
they can get a basketball match.
You can get 50 points ahead and there's no way you can lose.
But in a fight he could always lose.
It doesn't matter.
Accumulated scoring,
you get,
you gotta be fucking somebody out for three rounds for four minutes and 50
seconds and in the last 10 seconds they punch you and you go to sleep and they
win.
That's fucking nuts.
It's one of the reasons why it's so exciting.
It's also one of the reasons why we're never going to embrace soccer.
I embrace it.
Do you embrace it?
Yeah,
that's my penis.
What's wrong?
Are you okay?
How funny would it be if the US won the World Cup and nobody gave a fuck?
Who Cares?
No one does give a fuck that you're crazy.
And other countries is gigantic.
Okay.
You're getting negative.
We're going to end the podcast.
I feel your,
your blood sugar dropping.
I'm going to give you candy in the middle of the podcast.
Now scales you getting measurably less focused towards the end son.
You need a candy bar stun gun.
That was a good fight to Nick Diaz.
All right.
There's a lot of catch wrestling.
Yeah,
there's a lot of a,
I need to bring Mrs Rogan on.
Fuck you faggot.
Get your own wife.
Just staring at my wife.
Um,
the,
uh,
heard your wife's not doing transformers three.
Now shut up.
I got it.
Hold on.
You know,
I donate data actresses.
I have no head shots policy.
Very strict.
Usually till we all should in life.
Everyone should have a new head shots policy coming from the point of view of
someone with a headshot.
I guess I have one out there,
some somewhere.
But anybody who wants to be in the entertainment business,
who wants that kind of an exorbitant amount of attention?
You gotta be fucked up.
I'm fucked up.
Everybody else's.
It's a comic as fucked up.
Every actor's fucked up.
Every singer fucked up.
They're fucked up.
You're managing it.
You know,
you're trying to do your best with whatever fucked up energy habit.
The only reason why you're doing the first place,
cause you fucked up when you agree.
[inaudible] have you ever met a performance not fucked up in some way.
[inaudible] no,
it's possible.
Right?
That's the balance though,
my friend.
That is the balance of life.
You have to have some sort of a void in your life to be able to provide other
people with this sort of entertainment joy.
That's the engine.
That's the motivation behind that shit.
You know,
just like porn stars,
you have to be,
have a,
a,
you know,
a bad childhood.
If you want to let guys fuck you on,
on camera,
right?
There's gotta be something wrong there.
Right?
Or are you just totally love money or he took,
I guess you've got to really love money.
You know,
I think a,
there's a crazy balance to all life.
We've talked about this before,
but you know,
it's like what we were talking about when we're talking about third world
countries like and and idiots in America,
even you,
you,
you need a certain amount of unenlightened fools in this world to keep the world
operating on,
on the level that it's operating now you need a certain amount of people that
live in places where it's socks,
you know,
certain amount of people that live in impoverished countries and you need
corporations to exploit them in order to,
to keep this thing going the way it's going right now.
You know,
I'm not saying this is the only model that would function,
but this is the model that we currently operate under.
And in order to keep this model going,
you know,
I think what's happening is exactly what has to happen.
It really does seem like the more you pay attention to life,
that life is a program,
you know,
the more you,
you look at it all and look at the temporary nature of it all and you realize
that this really is some sort of a program we're following.
Don't you feel that all the time.
[inaudible]
and it doesn't feel real.
Right?
It feels,
it feels orchestrated.
Hmm.
Doesn't it?
[inaudible] I agree.
Oh my God,
you useless.
This is what I saw it this way.
So that's what made me,
why does,
what does I always talk about porn stars?
I guess cause I'm always beating off cause we love porn.
No,
I'm,
because I'm fascinated by that.
The world of it.
You know,
I'm,
I'm fascinated by all unusual human behavior.
I'm fascinated by strippers.
I'm fascinated by fighters.
I'm fascinated by Comedians,
entertainers,
performers,
all the,
the outskirts of,
of normal behavior.
Whether it's,
I don't mean none of it's bad.
It's all good.
I mean,
we all fuck.
Who Cares?
Fucking on camera.
There's nothing wrong with it.
We've all watched it.
We all benefit from it.
But this to me,
I'm,
I'm always fascinated by extreme types of behavior,
you know,
especially if they're not disturbing.
If it's not negative,
like,
you know,
we talked about the Max hardcore thing,
don't like that,
but I'm fascinated by all sorts of weird behavior.
I think it helps you understand your own,
don't you?
All right,
great.
After fucking two hours,
that's all Brian's sizes.
Yup.
I agree.
And I'm like,
listen,
you faggot.
Well I was thinking if I should even get into something because I don't want to
go any longer.
You know what I mean?
And I just had,
it's kind of scary to get to a point where you're like,
okay,
we need to end this,
but if I bring some,
we can talk for 20 minutes.
I was ready to bail at any moment.
I'm looking for a good moment to hell after two hours we looking for a good
moment to bail.
But if you have something interesting to talk about,
just talk.
All right.
Is there a proper way to,
when you know where you see porns where girls are giving blow jobs in,
right?
You're choking or gagging,
Uh,
is there a proper way to do it in a not a proper way to do it?
Like is there like a secret to it like you?
No,
I think it's the girl.
Some girls like that shit dude.
Right?
They're lucky to stuff it in or out.
They like to choke.
It's weird,
you know.
Um,
I don't think there's a secret way to do it.
I think mom is a total liar.
Then your mom told you something about porn?
Yeah.
What'd you say,
Brian?
Nothing.
Okay,
Brian,
now I know you're useless.
You were doing real good for about two hours there fella.
And there's nothing else to talk about.
Ladies and gentlemen,
give us another half an hour.
Listen,
the last half an hour it will suck.
Okay.
It'll be me talking to Brian and Brian checking his watch and looking at his
text messages.
He's right though.
You can't really do more than two hours and be interesting.
So,
uh,
and I think we're not interesting right now.
I think there's at the end of it,
um,
please stop doing that.
Get a penny next week.
I'm going to try to bring some other guests,
maybe some comics and see if I can gather anybody.
I'm a going to be a at the end part of this week,
so I'll come by and see if I grabbed somebody and bring some guys back here.
Make it interesting.
Um,
but let's say you get fucking tired fellow.
You're not thinking about the fact there's 1200 people listeners right now.
10,000 to go listen to it on Ustream.
Honestly,
I'm thinking about pissing my pants,
right?
Oh,
really?
Why don't you go up,
get up and take a leak?
You fucking freak.
All right.
You hanging in there hanging tough little kid.
But that's why he's so talented,
ladies and gentleman,
because he thinks like a child.
We all have.
We're all replaced in this world,
right,
Brian?
That's right,
Daddy.
All right.
Thank you ladies and gentlemen,
thank you very much for tuning in.
We appreciate it.
As always,
we will come back next week.
Uh,
I don't have any gigs until a couple of weeks.
I'm in Canada.
Go to Joe rogan.net.
You can see it all.
Last,
next big Gig in America as July 2nd in Vegas at the House of Blues.
Uh,
um,
so thank you very much for tuning in.
Everybody love you bitches.
And uh,
yeah,
go buy one of those things and fuck it.